With Watson pylons and then like caustic traps stacked on there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, it's okay.
Jen won yesterday's Twitch Rivals.
I got 19th place.
Ill average out.
And don't worry!
Ill average out!
I was on- look, I was on the fuck- I was on Wig's team, okay?
Like...
Oh, Tempo- what was Tempo doing?
He was charging the whole time, wasn't he?
We were- we were all of us.
We were all not- not gonna make it.
We're not- It's gonna average out!
We can average our rankings out from here.
Oh my god.
So it's looking like a ninth place or what?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's the average for that?
It's okay.
Apparently like only placements matter.
So we don't have to get any kills.
We just gotta be first to win money.
No, we got this.
We got this.
Yeah.
Oh, the odds are gonna be up by the way?
Yeah, the code's up.
The code's up.
I'm in it.
It's alright.
We got this.
We have Gen.
He won last Twitch Rivals.
He practically has the winning streak right now.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So I won Pro League and I won Twitch Rivals.
Exactly!
If you lose this game, all your cheapness never mattered.
If you lose this tournament, Gen, then that means the other wins, they were luck.
They were lucky.
This is where real skill matters now.
Punching and shit?
Like a man.
Yeah.
No weapons is real skill.
It's all about your brain at that point.
It's here to test your brain.
I have no brain.
I'm a controller.
Oh shit.
You're fucking right.
Oh dang.
Wait, do you have aim assist on punch?
No, no.
Wait, he does.
Wait, does he do?
Did he take that out?
No.
What?
He got rid of it.
Yeah, they got rid of aim assist on punch.
They got rid of it.
Why?
It used to be in the game.
Yeah, it was.
It used to be.
Aim assist on punching.
Why?
Controller players should have everything they want.
That's so true.
Yeah, might as well.
Give them everything.
Might as well.
They're basically keeping the game alive at the moment.
Wait, I can't find the code.
Where is it?
It's in the... It's in the code section.
It literally says code.
It has a PC icon or laptop icon.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
Yeah, first game.
What are we playing?
We're playing Fuse?
Caustic Watson.
Fuse Caustic Watson?
Yeah.
Okay.
I can do Watson.
I'll just put fences.
I'll be the fences girl.
I can do anyone but Fuse because I don't play him.
I don't have him unlocked because I hate him.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, you don't have him?
How many tokens do you have?
I do, but I played maybe like two games on Caustic realistically.
Wait, but just... you must have a million... I have a million Legend tokens.
You must have the tokens to unlock.
Oh, I do.
I don't do outspite.
I don't unlock them outspite.
Oh, so you don't like money.
Wait, wait, wait.
Spoons.
Hold up.
No, no, no.
Listen, listen.
So you don't like money?
I will call out Fuse if that's what it takes.
I'll do it.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait.
Spoons.
Is it because he's Aussie?
Is this...
Oh, is it because he's Australian?
Do you hate Australians?
He is Aussie, yeah.
I'm Australian too.
Nah, I took offence, cuz.
Ain't no way.
Do it.
Call her that way.
You have the pass.
Does that mean you have the pass?
Wait, but like... wait, he's like unlocked, right?
No.
Yeah, Fuse is... no, it's Mad Maggie.
Mad Maggie is unlocked this week.
Is everyone... are you... wait, we're waiting for someone.
Can I like unlock him really quick?
Yeah, yeah.
No, there's... you're fine.
There's like two people that's not here.
Okay.
I'm just gonna say, straight back, really quick.
Oh my god, I can't believe I'm... wait, he's in rotation though, I think.
No, it's nice.
Like, grenades are allowed, right?
Yeah, grenades are allowed.
I'll just unlock and be safe.
Okay.
This hurts.
I'm gonna carry an inventory full of grenades.
Yeah, yeah.
It's gonna be... if we get to endgame, we're set.
We're set.
All the fences, all the nades.
We don't need the grenades early, by the way.
Unless we're gonna kill someone.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, unless you're gonna get that stuck.
Okay.
Just get that stuck... that grenade stuck and you'll be fine.
This is literally my first time playing Fuse.
But it's okay, I'm really good at sticking Arcstars.
Okay, wait.
Do you wanna play... okay, I'll play Fuse, then you play Caustic.
No, no, no.
I think it's better if we have...
I think it's better if we have a good Caustic.
Cause Fuse, you're just kinda spammy.
I'm not a good Caustic, though.
Okay, but is he a good Caustic?
I'm gonna say like...
I'm the best.
I don't think I've ever seen him play Caustic willingly.
Has he ever played Fuse... like, Caustic willingly?
He's a controller player.
I feel like you don't know much about Fuse.
Hey, I won a championship with Caustic.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, yeah.
That's why you're playing Caustic.
I'm just saying.
Well, like, Fuse is OP.
You can stick people and shit.
Like, it's fun.
Oh, so then you don't wanna win if you... why would you do that?
Justify... yeah.
I'll play Caustic.
Fuse is the Clutch character.
All good.
We have plenty of time.
I think.
We were supposed to start like seven minutes ago, but Apex stuff never starts in time, so we're good to go.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We're good to go.
I just realized... okay.
Look at Team 1.
Please look at Team 1.
I wasn't gonna say that.
And Team 6 and Team 4.
Then Team 2.
How are these fair?
They're okay.
Because they're not using guns.
What the fuck do you mean?
Half of those players are controller players.
They don't have brains.
So what?
It's literally melee.
What are they gonna do?
Punch you better?
Yes.
Or coordinate punches better or something, I don't know.
Oh, yeah, when you become a pro player, you have to punch people better.
They add 10 plus more damage if you get into pro league.
Is that it?
For each?
Yeah, it's like a beach legend.
But imagine we survive to end zone, like Caustic ult, easy win.
Exactly, unless my Watson ult eats it.
That is true.
I think we can assume that every team will have a Caustic and Watson.
It's okay.
100%.
There's probably going to be one team with like a Crypto.
We have... yeah, I feel so.
Yeah, there has to be.
But it's okay.
I can put fences again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can Crypto ult me once, but I have infinite fences.
Well, we'll slap the ult ourselves too.
You're not real.
They're going to start punching the generator.
Not if you start punching the generator.
You punched them away from the gen.
We play protect the president.
The generator is our president.
It really is.
Wait, get the generator, the two generators.
Oh shit, you're right.
The two generator.
You're right.
They can't kill all the gens.
So what we do at the start of the game, we go run around.
And we just farm.
And we just farm fucking armor.
Oh my god, wait, you're right.
And then we go to zone.
Alright?
You're right, you're right.
You're thinking.
You're actually using your brain for real.
Hey, what brain?
Just tap into Zero's brain right now.
I'm tapping into it.
He's going to get rolled.
Dang.
He's nervous.
He's so nervous.
He's going to be so scared.
If you beat Zero, you can become IGL.
Really?
Yeah, that's the rules.
If you beat Zero, you can become IGL.
If you perform better than your IGL, you become the new IGL.
In a troll tournament though?
Yeah.
Are you serious?
How dare you?
This is a real tournament.
This has more money involved than Twitch Rivals.
What?
Twitch Rivals had...
How much was it?
I don't know.
This has more money involved than Twitch Rivals.
How dare you?
Is it actually?
Yeah.
This is a hundred...
Oh my god.
A hundred K?
Yeah, it's a hundred K prize pool.
But put that into Twitch Rivals, man.
I deserve that.
Yeah.
I won the game.
This is the one that matters.
You're right.
One game matters.
One game of this is half your prize winning from Twitch Rivals.
Oh my god.
Don't you dare tell me this is a troll tournament.
Now you're going to do it again today.
Just for this match though.
I need to say...
Just for this game.
And then you can like tone it down.
No, or he could win every game.
Oh wait, no, he's going to be not on our...
He's not going to be on my team.
So just this game.
You can win this game and then fuck off the next other games.
Yeah.
Wait, is it?
Wait, what?
Do we like change teammates every time?
Yeah, every game is a different team.
Oh, yalla bye.
Yeah.
This is the one that matters.
So if you win you get 1k.
Yeah, we win and we get 1k.
Exactly.
And we already... do we get like that $500 entry free?
I think we do, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
But when you make it to finals, you also get a free $500.
Oh fuck yeah.
Yeah.
So if we win this, that actually is half the Twitch Rivals winning.
And if you come 11th to 20th, you still get a hundred bucks.
Yeah.
You still get...
Well, this is a free money farm.
Exactly.
So it's not troll.
This is better than pro league.
This is serious.
How did this tournament is better than pro league?
Cause it's the finals.
You don't understand.
We worked so hard to get here.
I worked so hard to get here.
So how do you go for this?
So you see if you get like kill leader in GDMs or you have to get... win a game in BL?
Yeah.
You have to either win a game or become kill leader.
I mean that's easy.
Yeah.
That should be easy.
For you that's really easy right?
That's so easy.
Yeah.
I got this.
My... me and my two bronze badge... two bronze and plat badge.
We'll be fine.
Wait, where are we dropping?
We haven't even discussed our drops.
Where are we landing?
Oh, was it...
Oh, it was...
We're going to Overlook I think I saw earlier.
Are we going to Overlook?
I think so.
Wait, do we clean a spot?
I'm pretty sure that's what I saw Jen put but I could also be wrong.
Um... yeah yeah, Overlook I think.
I don't know if we're contested though.
Is it...
It's fine.
We're gonna get a dude to punch us out.
Right.
Oh no, we get it by ourselves.
We'll be fine.
There's no way.
There's no way they get us out.
We're gonna get...
I'll contest it.
Yeah.
How do you talk that much?
You talk more than me.
How's that possible?
It's called being a fucking professional Vtuber.
That's how.
Jesus man.
I don't think I can sign up for five seconds, you know?
It's because when you don't have aim, you have to compensate it with other stuff to make people watch you.
Jesus.
You're a professional, yeah, bro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got a degree in Michigan or what?
They're not here to watch me for my aim.
They're here to watch me for relatability.
For the vibes.
Yeah, for the vibes and the relatability.
Because if I can make it in this tournament, anybody can in your chat.
You hear that chat?
Why you guys not in here?
You guys suck.
That's right.
No, no, no.
That means you have a chance.
My aim might not be as good as Shen, but I can win as more money than him, maybe.
You're kidding me.
If I out-earned Gen in this tournament, in this tournament, that means you can, too.
So prior to this, I had $500 earning in this tournament.
Yeah, $500.
All of us do.
All of us?
Okay, okay.
I'm as equal to Gen right now.
My prize winnings is as equal to Gen.
It'll be fine.
You know Horizon Doki?
Oh, yeah.
It was really fun.
Horizon, yeah?
The British kid.
Yeah, you talk more than him.
I talk more than...
Isn't he the Spider-Man kid?
Yeah, the Spider-Man kid.
Oh, that sounds like Tom Holland?
Yeah, Tom Holland.
Tom Holland, yeah.
It's a good thing.
Yeah, that's good.
That means he's entertaining.
It is.
Yeah, he already has a friend.
Finally!
He's Tom Holland at Walmart.
Walmart Tom Holland.
Well, actually no.
Tom Holland at Wish.
That seems more like it.
Nah, I'm gonna tell him about that.
Yeah.
He's gonna start crying.
He's gonna stay...
Are we landing again?
Overlook?
Yeah, we're at Overlook.
Oh yeah, good.
We can just start farming armors from them.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm on Watson.
Alright, I have you selected, Clay.
Just unlocked him.
Okay.
Oh my god, you scared me.
Where the fuck is Watson?
Oh, there he is.
Hey, fuck!
He's like, wait, my bank card.
Yeah.
We're champion at Tostik.
So you have Fuse not unlocked, but you have a skin for him.
How does that work?
Yeah, how does that work?
I spent a lot of money on this game.
I'll just say that.
And not Fuse?
Wait, you spent money on a free-to-play game?
Yeah, I'm living free on this game.
No, because like when there's the Heirloom events, like, I'll buy out the events, so I'll get certain skins.
So you spent money on a free-to-play game, so you spent...
Alright, drop us to victory.
I'm gonna go get some skins.
I don't get how you think that justifies you spending money on events.
But it really doesn't.
Like, I do not want to look at my, like, Steam purchase history for this game.
I'll actually cry, I think.
Mentally I'll never be able to recover.
That's okay.
I actually spent money on the Mirage statue, so it's okay.
Recently, like, I was kind of spending money on this game, and then recently, I haven't been.
I've been getting things for free, you know?
Yeah, that's...
Yeah, me too!
You know those epic stacks that I got?
Yeah, the destroyer one, right?
2000.
The destroyer packs.
Yo, that guy is hurting me for real!
He gave me two and a half for free!
Bro, is he in chat right now?
You wanna hack us real quick again?
He saved me $300 from this event!
I'm just saying!
Alright, let's lock in.
Alright, look, if things don't do so well, maybe he'll hack your game and you'll be back to life or something.
Okay, I'm gonna grab...
We can grab healers and stuff, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that would be fucked up if we can.
I'm not gonna lie, I grabbed, like, a flatline vault.
I was ready to shoot.
Oh my god!
Wait, can we, like, grab guns and throw the guns at them to distract them?
I thought that worked.
Oh, no, no, no!
Wait, no!
Imagine guns are damaged when you throw at them.
No, think of it this way.
We grab the gun, throw it at them, and then they shoot us and then they get disqualified.
Oh my god.
Because they think they pick it up!
You might be cooking a little too hard.
You're cooking too much food!
What do you mean?
They're gonna, like, pick up the gun and then... they'll pick up the gun accidentally because you throw it at them.
And then they shoot at them.
Oh my god.
Then they get disqualified for using the gun.
Because they didn't think we can't have it in our inventory.
I can't.
It works!
I bet you that.
Can you hear me fusing?
Wait, so, can you have a gun on you, though?
We won't be using it.
I don't know.
What if you shoot it, like, accidentally?
It's not fun.
Yeah, but if you don't shoot it at a person, it should be fine, right?
Okay, I'm carrying an alternator.
You're gonna carry an alternator.
I'm carrying an alternate.
I'm carrying it.
Why are you throwing the gun at a person?
Oh my god, we should throw a gun at a person.
I have a Mozambique too.
Oh my god.
Wait, Tempo's watching!
Fuck, Joppa, he's in my chat!
He said he's watching!
Joppa, Joppa, Joppa, Joppa.
Throw the gun!
Drop the gun!
Drop the fucking gun!
It was an accident!
Yo, Tempo, bro, come on.
I didn't know I had it on.
It was just like my brain was automated to loot.
Yeah, he's a controller player.
You should...
Help me.
You think they actually think about what they're doing?
He's literally a controller player.
Alright, I'm gonna get this juicer.
Someone get this one here.
Oh, okay, okay.
That one.
Can you land over here?
I don't... I don't think so.
Oh my god.
There's a Giga tower over there.
You know, we should've gotten Octane and had an Octane just walk right around picking up the things.
Wait, is someone here?
Yo, what's up, girl?
Wait, are they going for the thing?
They should be going for the armor.
I guess we hit this one here.
I'm starting off.
Alright, do we want the revive 50 HP or the falling stars one?
Oh, the falling stars, I think.
Falling stars?
Okay.
Which one do I get, actually?
Falling range.
Wait, which one do I get?
Guys, we're doing well.
You wanna see how far I fall?
Look at this shit, bye!
Alright, guys, guys, we gotta get the other one.
Oh my god, bro, we gotta go to the Olympics.
Holy fuck.
Holy shit, shot put master.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's grab this one and then we should find some...
We got some stuff to open, too.
Oh wait, I can do the ring console.
Wait, wait, wait, I'm gonna split up.
Yeah, okay, let's get the juicer and then get the ring console.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And open our salt bin.
There's no way I'll get punched out on the ring console.
There's no fucking way.
No, no, no, no, if they do, I'll just snade them.
Yeah, yeah, no, I'm gonna...
I'll make a ring...
I'll make a ring around the ring console.
So they can't...
I can't come punch you this way.
They can't punch me out if there's a barrier.
This is it.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my gosh, my brain is cooking up some...
...six shots for this.
We just need tempo to not watch and we'll be fine.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There's people here.
They punched a barrel?!
I can't see them.
Whoa.
Oh god.
I just saw that man fucking...
...punch the loop... the loop cart.
Like, out of the sky?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Bro, he was gaming!
Guys, okay.
Alright, Jenny, I'm gonna...
Wait, actually, I'm gonna make a ring around the thing.
I'm gonna make traps over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta surround ourselves.
Hit that shit.
Okay.
I can hit it too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna surround you.
So they can't...
But you put me in a cage, bro!
That's right.
Alright.
We're...
We're two armors.
There's a...
There are two armor bins away.
Alright.
From the purple.
Is that good for this one here?
Yeah, yeah.
I'll get that.
Get that one and then I'm gonna get this one here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
Wait.
No, we don't have any supporter.
I was gonna say we could craft ourselves, but we can't.
We can't craft ourselves.
Alright, I'm grabbing the other bin.
I desperately need a backpack.
You can't carry all these nades.
I only have two...
I only have two nades.
Wait.
One team died already.
How did they...
We're not 20th...
They got shit on!
I don't know.
Bro!
How are you that bad?
If Doki say, how are you that bad?
It's over.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
You know...
You know who was the 20th place?
But Design died apparently.
Design!
No way.
We've got a shot team.
Bro!
That's really sad though, right?
That's embarrassing.
Okay, I'm just gonna stand here in the open and look carefully at my abilities.
Not last officially achieved.
He threw some knuckle...
Wait.
I think...
Minus 50% explosive damage.
I feel like that's wrong.
Should we get red armor?
Probably?
I don't know.
Should we just get zoned?
We might as well.
I mean, I feel like zoned doesn't really matter, right?
Oh, yeah.
Chur's gonna run around the...
Yeah, everybody's just running around.
Who does he...
Can we pull it up?
I feel like...
No, I think we should be together because I feel like people are actually gonna...
Because everybody's just gonna...
Yeah, everybody else is gonna...
Oh, do you have any OX allosoki?
No.
Wait, someone landed behind me.
Oh, I have one.
You good?
You're good.
Wait, I can pick that up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we need all the...
All right, I'm gonna go to...
I'm gonna hit the gen.
All right, Dohki, did you put the...
Did you get the two generators?
The two gen...
Yeah, I did.
I did.
Don't worry.
Nice.
I got you.
There's no...
I saw a lot of fuses, so thank god we're watching.
Guys, it's a little scary at endgame.
Oh, it's gonna be awful.
I feel like we should...
Oh, we can get another ring console.
We should get that.
Yeah, ring console.
Oh, should we get this one too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should just get...
Grab one in the 40.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just grab everything so we can have red armor in the end.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We just...
The moment we hit late game, we're GG's.
It's gonna be...
We're good to go.
We have like, Watson for two.
Your brain is working over time, you know?
I think like...
I mean, if we really...
Do you know end zones, Jen?
Really?
Yeah.
You have to.
Okay.
I was like, there's no way you don't.
No, no.
There's some pros that don't.
There's...
No, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
What are you trying to say?
Huh?
I'm just trying to say that you're one of the pros that do know it.
I hit the 50-50.
But the others, why?
Is it because they're on the import or...
I don't know.
What are you trying to imply?
What do you mean by input?
What do you...
Well, you used to play the game.
What do you mean?
I didn't imply anything.
I never...
I just said some pros just don't know.
Are you trying to say controller players are too stupid to know?
Yeah, that's true.
I'm not even gonna deny it.
Okay.
I put a cage around this one.
So, if anyone wants to...
Deny.
Do that.
I'm not even gonna deny it.
So, if anyone wants to...
Do that.
That ring comes so they can't...
I'm gonna go grab this armour.
Wait, there's somebody in here.
What, I'm grabbing this juicer.
Okay.
Grabbing that juicer?
Wait, okay.
Do you think I'd be safe if I grab the other armour one?
I should be.
That one?
There's people right here on me, so...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm going to get my chip beater.
Oh, wait, do I have EVAX?
EVAX could be just...
I do not have any...
No, I have a mobile reason.
I'm gonna punch people on the evac so they can keep taking over and over again.
The sky fees me.
Woah!
I was watching them.
Are you on top?
Spoons?
No, no, no.
Oh, no, right here.
There's a lot of people fighting here right now.
Okay, wait, Jhin, what's endgame?
Endgame is, um, literally... on us.
Oh, someone is pushing.
Oh, it is?
Okay, I'm gonna head over to you.
It's fine, you'll be fine, you'll be fine, just run.
Uh-oh.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Just run.
They're right on top of you.
I'm heading to Jhin.
I'm running.
I can't take the balloon to you guys.
Wait, I'm literally right with you.
Can we play like a piece of shit?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, right here.
Wait, they're fucking coming.
No, they're not, they're too free.
They're like on you.
There's no, no, no, don't look back.
If you don't look back, you're not there.
Right, they're actually gonna punch us.
In a way.
Yo, peace out, bro.
The fuck?
Woah!
What are they doing?
They're wasting names.
Play this corner, play this corner.
Okay.
What the fuck are they doing?
They're wasting good, valuable names.
It's fine, it's fine, they're dumb.
Yeah, they're so dumb, I know.
Keep doing it, keep throwing your names.
They have to be controller.
This guy's definitely controller.
Oh, fuck it!
Yeah, yeah, run.
Yeah, fucking run.
We didn't waste our names.
We have a fuse for that.
Okay, look, I made us a little ring.
Okay, they have a den now.
I have like seven, eight grenades.
Alright, nice.
I have a...
I think nine.
I have two.
I didn't loot that much.
I just realized I did.
I might not have looted as much as I wanted.
Just keep breaking the fences, spoons and shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just don't know if they have gen up yet.
You want a generator?
No, I couldn't tell if they have.
No, they do have a generator.
No, they don't.
This team has a gen.
He's just sitting there.
Does that team have a gen?
Which team?
Yeah, they do.
Everybody has a gen.
I'm not gonna waste my gen, because no one's throwing names at us.
Actually, I'm gonna throw a gen.
Actually, maybe I should.
Actually.
They can't get rid of this.
I have two pylons, too.
Nice.
He's looking.
Oh my god, I'm pulled down on my thing.
What's up, bruh?
Alright, this is our space.
Get out.
Wait, how much more...
How many more fences?
I have two more fences.
You can pull a 12 down?
How many?
I broke their fence.
Two more.
How many Sofus and Mijigas?
I'm just gonna make it longer.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna make it longer.
Oh, look at them.
Look at their baby cage.
We have so much space here.
Yeah, literally.
Look at our space.
Oh, I got him again.
Get shit on.
Yeah, waste your gen.
I'm just breaking their fences because they're setting it really far from their gen.
People playing Newcastle, that's troll.
I guess...
Oh, I think for endgame.
That's really good for endgame.
Well, Newcastle's not gonna save them from costing gas.
That's true.
Have you guys seen any gibbies yet?
I don't think I've seen a gibby.
Me neither.
I haven't seen a crypto yet either, honestly.
This is good because you can hold like two grenades per slot.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, they took away my space.
I'm gonna steal their fences here.
Okay, I can break that in five seconds.
Okay.
Wait, I still want to...
Haha!
Oh, okay.
They connected to mine.
Dude, I dare you to put a fence down.
Yeah, fucking do it, coward.
Oh, they took them again.
Come on.
What the fuck are you doing, Jen?
What are you doing?
My fucking gen.
Oh, my god.
What?
Wait, they're grabbing reinforcements.
No!
That's fucked up.
Get out.
That's fucking right.
Leave.
I have nades too.
No, I want to go back.
I dare you to move away.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, break their fences here so I can take their fence.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait, actually, no, no, don't break it.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Oh, god.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm good.
I have a nade.
Leave!
Don't make me throw this nade.
Don't make me...
Oh, you guys, I'll do it.
Oh, my god, that tap straight.
Wait, did you throw a nade?
Oh, no, that's your canister.
I'm going to throw it at their head.
You're going to throw...
Chuck it.
Wait, how far can you chuck the...
We're literally in guns.
See, I told you.
We're chilling.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Let's get away.
Oh, my god.
Let's go to the side door.
I don't know which side.
It could be this side or this side.
It's probably our side.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
As long as...
We're in a perfect spot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're okay.
This team has to move forward to us then.
Oh, he's fucking with you.
This team has to move to us.
Red.
We should try farming to red, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, we should.
We should.
I have a thousand.
He's trying to stick me, bro.
What the fuck?
Bro, what is he going to do?
After he sticks you, he plucks you?
If they stick you, I will literally ult you guys.
Okay.
Don't worry.
And then you'll have to fight to death in the ring of fire.
No!
Wait, that's smart.
We can spawn in the unlimited arc stars, by the way.
Do you have the perk?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have the spawn arc stars.
This should do it.
Okay, hold up.
But I can't do it for myself?
I don't...
He didn't spawn any yet.
It's because we haven't thrown anything at our gen yet.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I...
Can I Q this?
Wait, wait.
What if I...
Wait, they're rotating.
They're rotating.
Look, cowards.
They're cowards.
Actual pussy.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I'm gonna punch their gen.
Wait.
Did they spawn on the arc star?
Did they do it again?
What?
Wait.
They don't know.
I don't know where they're falling.
Okay, they patched it.
They patched it.
Wait, did they?
Oh.
I bet the enemy has to do it, yeah.
No.
They took over.
They took over the area.
Okay.
I'll break the fence again in seven seconds.
Can't believe it.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna pick up this and then cage them here.
You're gonna cage them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna cage them here.
They're in my gas!
They're gas in the gas tank!
Oh my god, nice, nice.
Yeah, that's right.
I can put one good grenade on the...
Oh shit, wait, there's people in here!
Oh shit, okay, never mind.
I'm gonna... you're not caged anymore.
Those weirdos.
Oh, they put another gen there too.
I'm gonna put a fence here.
Alright.
Do you have traps though?
A loba?
What the fuck are you gonna do with a loba?
There's no loot here.
Nobody's dead.
There's literally 19 squads.
That is a brain dead thing.
What are you gonna get?
Wait, wait, is one team a rat?
Nooooo?
Question mark?
Oh, no, someone just died.
I can't do math.
We can play!
Start setting up here, come here.
Start setting up here.
Alright, don't worry, I got you.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna grab these fences.
On this rock.
Yeah, yeah, quick, quick, quick.
Okay.
Extending.
Oh, someone on you!
Woooah!
What the fuck?
Don't worry!
Oh, oh my god!
I'll do it!
We'll have to get back to it.
It's fine!
We're fine!
I'm putting as many fences as possible!
They're in my fence!
Oh my god, I'm seeing an orange stone!
What the fuck?
Put fucking fences down!
But they're in my fences!
They're in my fences!
Oh my god!
They're still trying to punch it!
The fucking hell, man!
They're punching the fence!
They're punching the fences!
It's okay, we're fine.
I'm punching the fence!
Wait, go!
Go, go, go, go!
You're fucking crazy!
Oh god.
There we go!
Don't worry, I connected everything.
There are more traps down there.
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Wait, who's there?
Who's on the fence?!
It's okay.
Someone else is blocking right here.
It's okay, we still... they can't come in.
We gotta chill, we gotta chill.
They can't come in here.
They're still trying to punch my fences, but I'm just putting them back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Fuck you, Kosti!
Yeah, fuck off!
Lucky bitch!
Kosti, try to break the wall!
It's okay, it's okay, we're fine, we're fine.
I still have my fences, we're fine.
No, no, no!
Come on!
What's with all these mobis?
Oh god.
Oh god, oh god.
Okay, we don't have fences on our backs anymore, by the way.
I got lots of them.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, I was gonna stick one.
No!
Oh, I'm okay.
Oh my god, they're still fucking fencing it up!
Okay, jump down, jump down!
We can play on me too.
Maybe start fencing this side.
Come, come, come.
Right here, right here.
Fuck those guys, I don't like them.
They have ult?
No, no, no, no, I don't.
We gotta protect the gen then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we gotta protect it.
They're throwing nades and stuff on our gen.
We're fine.
I'm 62%.
I have ult, I'll try to use it.
Okay, the end...
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna...
I can put a gen down...
I have a gen, I have a gen.
Yeah, okay.
I'm gonna do it.
And then ult, excel for the next one.
I already used my ult, excel for this gen.
Yeah, yeah.
Unless you guys have...
No, I gave you my only one.
I'll try and break some stuff over here.
Okay, I have a ring.
I have a ring!
We're gonna have to start breaking fences soon.
I'm breaking, hold up.
Okay, okay.
Bro.
This team is still here.
Oh, I said nothing!
Okay, we have...
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
We gotta keep breaking their fences.
We have...
Oh my god.
Oh, yo, chill bro!
They're trying to fight, yo.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're good, we're good.
On the left.
We're fine.
They're breaking the fences for us!
They're breaking it for us!
They're clearing the path!
We're actually chilling.
They cleared the path, they cleared the path!
We just need them to clear... Yeah, look, look, look!
They cleared the path for us!
All my ping!
Okay.
This is gonna be hell.
This is actually gonna be a dead end!
We can't use them!
I'm good, I'm good.
We have to move up soon.
We have to put a generator like here.
I don't have it, I don't have it!
Did you use the ulti-kill?
Yeah, I already used it for our other gen.
When did you get a new one?
Oh, far.
We used their gens!
They have gens that we can use!
It'll be fine.
We used their generators.
We can't name anyone!
So fun!
Push this condo out!
Yeah, yeah, they're smacking fences!
We have to start...
Guys, we have to start the slowing fences.
Close it, close it!
The fuse!
Oh my god.
They're so many.
No way, I can't even ult, man.
Go on the care package!
Wait, the care package, maybe the care package.
Oh my god, I messed up!
I'm going on the care package!
Guys, I'm not doing so well, guys.
I'm not okay!
I'm fucking chilling on the care package!
I'm sucking on you!
The care package is very good!
Guys, it is hell.
Wait, wait, put the shield.
I don't know which one you guys are.
Do you feel the shield?
That's me, that's me, that's me.
You good like turkey?
You good?
No, I'm not!
I don't feel good!
Bro, what the fuck?
I don't feel so good!
Bro, I got knocked out!
Jack, this sucks to you!
What the fuck is going on?
I'm trying, I'm trying!
Oh my god, I can't move!
I can't move!
Oh my god!
I'm getting placement!
No!
I'm insane!
Who won?
Bro, what the fuck?
That was fucking insane!
Where was the crypto we needed?
Nobody picked crypto!
I could not move!
Holy shit!
The fuck was that gangbang man?
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
That is actually crazy!
I could not move!
No, I got blocked by 20 people in front of me!
I was stuck!
We got six though!
Nice, nice!
No one crypto for real!
No one went crypto, so there was just offenses everywhere!
The Newcastle won!
Holy fuck!
Newcastle won dude!
The Newcastle wants to play!
Who would've thought?
Newcastle and Valkyrie, dang!
Oh my god!
What even happened?
Yo, we got 400 bucks off that though!
Fucking take it!
How much did we win?
400!
400?
Easy!
Okay, now for the rest of the game, just throw.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you don't have to try anymore.
Are you sure?
I'm racking up the bag.
Yeah, you already got that money.
You already got the 400 dollars.
You can just relax now.
Maybe try MNK out for a bit.
Bro, you can't say that he's actually good at mouse and keyboard!
Is he?
Yeah!
I'm actually master's level.
I watched your fucking, what was it, one stream?
41 hour stream.
Yeah, the one where you fucking went crazy the longer it went.
The one on RK.
Yeah.
The bronze to field.
The one where you just started talking to yourself at one point because you were- What?
When did I do that?
You did!
You were starting to talk to yourself in that stream and I was like, this man's not okay.
Yeah, I was 41 hours deep.
What are you looking at me?
Yeah, that's what I meant!
You were not okay!
I did a 48 hour before that too.
And I was talking to myself.
I was seeing shit.
You know Mandy got a haircut?
Mandy got a haircut.
I saw her on stream live that day.
And I looked to my wall, right?
I could see him.
I could picture it.
You could see him?
I could see him, yeah.
He was right next to me type shit.
Bro, what the fuck?
That leopard shit.
You mean Mandy is your fucking sleep paralysis demon or some shit?
He might be.
He's my girlfriend.
Damn.
Alright, teams are out.
Oh, I think we got- Wait.
Oh, we're on the same team again.
For real?
Yeah.
We're on the same team.
Oh, dang.
So, we're replacing you with Timmy.
Wait.
I don't- I can't believe you got replaced with Timmy.
No lifeline.
Alright, good luck I guess.
Yeah, good luck.
Good luck.
Bye.
Alright, team 20.
Alright, let me...
I'm going to team 20 now.
Me too.
Alright, we got this.
Hello!
Hello.
How did your team do, Timmy?
We got 12.
Were you in that clusterfuck?
We were climbing a rock and someone kamikazed me into the zone.
And I phased.
And I spawned in.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's good.
The end game...
You didn't want to be in that mosh pit.
That shit was- That mosh pit was fucked up.
I've never felt so useless.
I was like, I'm used to standing with a bag full of nades.
Can't even use them all.
The fact that there was no crypto.
Nobody actually picked a crypto.
It was very surprising.
One person at least got to play crypto.
Everyone was like, I know the other team is going to play crypto.
I was like, Watson, Caustic, Fuse, and then of course the Newcastle team won.
That was pretty shocking.
Wait, okay, but- Newcastle is the move.
Yeah, but the thing is, the next one is three strikes.
And it doesn't say no Newcastle.
Just no Lifeline.
It also says, it doesn't say no Mirage.
Okay, okay, I was going to say, what the fuck was play Mirage?
But I'm like- Wait, wait, wait, I want to do Mirage.
Wait, I want to be Mirage.
Yeah, go for it, go for it.
Okay, I need...
people to leave team 20 so we can join team 20.
Um, so, I also unfortunately cannot play Newcastle.
I could try.
Wait, wait, wait.
What should we do for comp then?
Well, I can play Newcastle if you want to play Mirage.
I'm down for that too.
Yeah, yeah, because I've like, you know, I've played Newcastle in...
Lifeline and Three Strikes because I'm that fucked up as a person.
Oh no, no, I definitely played Lifeline and Three Strikes.
Whatever it takes.
Whatever it takes to win, you know, pubs are that important for the regular person.
We don't have much.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, um, honestly I haven't played, like, uh, Three Strikes in a while.
So, I mean, I know that obviously the comp is Lifeline, Newcastle.
Yeah, but we can't have Lifeline.
Yeah.
So I think Newcastle...
I do think people are probably going to play Conduit as well.
Yeah, true.
Conduit's really good.
I can also play Conduit.
Yeah, it's probably like a Newcastle, Conduit, and I don't really know what that last one would be.
I think like Mirage, because imagine someone gets downed, you can just crawl forever until you find your little Mirage.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter because people don't die anyway.
So, when you're down...
Yeah, and then you get a little stealth res off.
What I was thinking, is I don't know if it actually works, but if we play Lifeline, I think Lifeline could be good.
Oh, we can't play Lifeline.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Did you get sleep?
I'm bricked up in my head right now.
Jesus Christ.
Are you okay?
What happened?
You get trauma dumped here.
I got a big dent in my head right now.
Oh shit!
Alright, alright.
So, what are you cooking to me?
What are you cooking?
I lost all cookage after that.
After like Spoons and I was like, you know, there's still a Lifeline three times in a row.
You guys are saying it too many times that I thought like honestly, yeah, it's been Lifeline.
You know what?
What is Temple gonna do?
Kick me out of scrims?
He wouldn't.
Yeah, he would never do that to you.
He would never.
He would just kick you out of every tournament he organizes.
Alright.
What...
Um...
I don't really know.
I'm not gonna lie.
Cause we can play um...
We could play safe.
If you wanna play safe.
We could also play like somewhat aggro and such rotate.
Or we could just play full aggro.
That's like kind of the three options.
Well the thing is that Tempo set kills don't matter.
It's all about placement.
I think everyone's gonna be playing for placement.
Which is why we had like 18 squads at like round 5 or something last match.
Yeah.
So I think if we play too aggressively we'll just die.
Also there's like some fucked up teams too.
There's some like team 4...
There's team 4.
There's team 5.
There's... I don't know how aggressive we can play guys.
Guys, team 8 with Amu and snipedown.
The thing about when I played this um...
There was a tourney back then.
It was I think before the Evo system was changed.
We pretty much wanna get red armors before we get to end game.
Because if we pretty much don't have loot.
You know what I mean?
Like if we don't have loot and then we go into the final we're most likely not going to win.
So we pretty much need triple red armor or roughly purple armors.
And a lot of meds and nades.
And I don't know how much we're going to get realistically from our off drop.
Wait, where are we landing?
What's our drop point?
That's a great question.
I think we go north pad.
It's okay.
They will never bully you out of your drop spot.
You're Timmy.
Yeah, yeah.
Right?
They would never.
They see your name.
They're like we can't contest them.
It's Timmy.
Yeah.
Alright, we're gonna go north pad.
It's gonna be an edge type of um...
POI.
We should roughly get purples by the time we leave.
Um, I I think honestly I'm probably just gonna play Wraith.
It would be easy.
And then just do the Newcastle and um...
What was it?
Conduit.
Okay, Newcastle, Conduit.
Okay.
Because Conduit is really good for end game when there's a lot of teams.
You have that Conduit ult, Newcastle Rezzas.
I could port us back or port us into positions because people are gonna play zone and they're gonna be like a bunch of crazy spots.
So if I can just port us into a spot and then be Newcastle ult, we should be fine.
Alright.
I'll do... I'll be Newcastle.
And I'm down to Conduit.
Cool.
Yeah, look at that.
Look at you cooking.
You know, I believe in us.
I see the vision.
Yeah, I see Timmy's vision right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will let you know there is gonna be a lot of revenant Conduits running around.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, revenant.
If you see a revenant, I think it's best for us to turn around.
But in general, it's hard to kill a revenant Conduit.
I played you anyways in ranked.
But yeah, I do think there...
I feel like Jen Burton is gonna be on revenant and he will kill us all.
It's okay.
That's why we have two more choices.
We have two more strikes and then we know where he is so we fly away from there.
Exactly.
You fly to the opposite side of the zone and you know you're safe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
We're like... we're peaceful.
Like, what are they gonna do?
Kill us?
As long as one of us is standing, they can't.
So we'll be fine.
Yeah, there's no way.
In Apex Legends?
Newcastle...
Where the fuck is Newcastle?
We can craft!
Oh wait, we don't...
Yeah!
No, we can't craft.
You guys never die forever.
Nevermind.
You're picking too hard.
Guys, I thought too hard.
We can play lifeline.
Pick a lifeline.
Yeah, we're picking a lifeline!
Let's do it!
I was actually gonna be like, oh my god, let's pick lifeline.
Don't worry.
Tempo likes me so he'll restart the game for me.
Easy.
It'll be easy.
If I accidentally...
Honestly, can he just tell us the zone?
Cause he can see the zone.
Oh, it's true!
Let me message Tempo real quick.
I'll tell him I'm never...
Let me blackmail Tempo real quick.
Alright, we're dropping.
We might be contested.
Oh.
Woah!
You told him to end right now?
Yeah, I did!
I told you!
You had that much power.
I have that much power!
I told him to end the game.
Look at that.
He actually did it.
I did this.
Smile.
In the presence of greatness.
He knew...
I have that much power.
Do we have Hot Drop or no?
Uh, I don't...
Not that game.
No, no, no, we didn't.
Wait, apparently...
Apparently Reps...
Wait, was it Reps or...
Oh, Verhulz!
No, it was Verhulz.
Yeah, Verhulz!
It was on fucking Lifeline.
Oh my god.
That could've been us.
Are we the only team that are playing...
Why are there so many Caustics?
Okay, people are playing Caustics.
That makes me want to change my mind.
Do we still want Conduit?
Um...
No, they're playing our comp.
They're just swapping our wraith for a Caustic.
Which, honestly, I would probably just ditch, dude.
You're gonna conform?
No, actually, no, you're right.
Let those...
You're right, you're right.
We're gonna team with the wraith player.
I know!
I can't believe you're gonna be a Meta slave.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't believe it.
What happened to you?
You've changed.
I almost changed, right there.
Probably changed you.
The peer pressure was actually pretty crazy.
I know, probably changed you!
You wouldn't let Meta help decide what you play.
We're here to craft...
We're here to theorycraft, not be the sheep.
They're with the wild cards.
We're about to win this.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Wild cards always win.
That's why we're wild.
Are you guys... Question, are you MNK or Roller?
MNK.
We're the MNK squad.
We're so fucked.
Wait, wait, we're fucked?
What are you talking about?
MNK is up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, listen.
Long range, long range fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, now we can actually use our guns, so it's fine.
It's okay, I'll contact Destroyer2009.
We can get some aim assist.
Oh shit, you're right, you're right.
Slip him a little 50 under the table.
Mhm.
Give us walls as well.
With that extra 50.
Alright, we're looking okay.
We're looking good.
Alright, you guys can land at the... over here.
Probably stood off me.
Yeah, I'm gonna loot over here.
I'm gonna go to the middle here.
Yeah, just be careful, because when people die, they can always...
they land on you.
I think the closest thing is checkpoint maybe?
I'll get that.
I don't know how the respawns work, but there's a chance that people just don't know you're there, and then they just land on you.
Yeah, I mean we just look up if they...
Oh my god, someone already got knocked.
Alright, I'll go on the right side.
Oh my god, it's a trap.
It feels weird grabbing guns.
Feels like I'm doing something.
It's not loud.
Awww.
We're running.
Nemi R9.
There's a Carbine here if anyone wants it.
I'm alright.
Do we need an Evo?
There's an Evo here.
We want to grab that.
Yeah.
We will grab that.
Yeah, because we are...
We're in our whiteys.
We need marksman weapons.
We'll have to grab them.
The blue heavy mag.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I'll loot the house in front.
Wait, did you loot the...
Oh, you looted the far right.
Okay.
I'm gonna loot the house.
Wait, does the design died again?
Is he 20?
No, he's not 20 in place at least.
No teams in white.
There's a purple bag here.
Oh, let's see.
I haven't played Newcastle in a while.
Should I get the swift shield or the thick shield?
Can you read them to me?
Mobile shield gains 250 HP.
Increase mobile shield speed to weapon speed sprint.
Probably the HP one.
Alright.
There's a blue bag here.
Oh, we all have blue bags.
We're fine.
Fine.
We're healthy.
There's a purple mag.
We're fine.
Level 3.
I'm gonna crack the bot.
I'm cracking something.
And then for your...
Can you read me the other one as well?
What's your level 2?
Oh.
My level 3 is 250 castle wall HP or allies are revived with health regen up to 75.
The first one.
Don't we already regen when you...
Or does it regen on top of that too?
No, no, no.
It's just an instant HP.
We res with 100 every single time.
So there's no point in getting the second one.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So the stronghold, right?
The castle wall HP, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Because I read it out of order.
So I was like, wait a minute.
And then for your conduit one, can you read me your conduit abilities?
Oh, I do the 10% jammer and then I usually do the gain an extra tackle charge instead of the range.
I'm trying to think.
Yeah, that's about it.
Right.
I'm not too sure, honestly.
I think that one's just good because it...
Like you get it so often.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we should get the...
We should grab the harvesters.
Yeah.
We should do the prowlers right now so we can get potentially close to purple.
Alright, let's go.
I'm here.
Phew.
Where's the other prowlers?
Nobody's coming out.
Shoot it.
Oh, this one's so far away.
Oh.
Is the shooting the prowlers thing a myth or is it actually true?
Wait a minute.
Was that somebody landing?
You back four?
Shooting it does actually do something.
Oh, okay.
That's not a myth.
It's real.
After a certain amount of time, you shoot it and then...
It's kinda just making noise.
I knew it was real.
No, it touched me.
I dropped a 2x if anyone wants it.
I am...
7.
Let's see.
Actually, I'll probably take that.
I mean...
Is there any extra light ammo?
I can drop your stuff.
It's fine.
I have like...
I have 100 right now.
Okay.
I'm just curious.
I have...
I'll be
fine.
Shoot this down?
This flyer that we're driving to?
Yeah.
It's almost dead.
It's dead.
Oh, it's purple.
I'm gonna grab it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Phoenix shit.
Oh, do you grab the... you got?
I did.
Yeah, I did.
Oh, wait.
I grabbed it.
Sorry, I'm bad at driving.
That's why our pro player will drive for us.
Yes, yes.
I got you.
Can you grab this?
Yeah, I'll grab it.
Okay.
Um...
We are gonna grab this one.
And then we craft the medkit there.
Alright.
Wait, there's people here.
No, no.
It's just...
The zone... Oh, the zone drops them?
Yeah, yeah.
The zone hits...
Oh, this guy is here though.
Damn!
We fight them, fight them, fight them.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got one, I got one.
I'm going in.
Boom!
Okay, I'm right behind them.
Watson, Watson low.
Nice.
Let's go.
Okay, look at us.
Wait, I'm looking up just in case.
Just in case.
They're gonna come back.
They're angry.
They're so angry.
I'm looking up.
No, they're not.
They're not.
They don't wanna fly in the zone.
They're way too stupid for that.
Okay.
They don't want the...
They don't want the smoke.
Yeah, yeah.
I got two medkits for you guys.
Any of you guys need batteries?
I got bat.
I craft a bat too.
I should be good.
Good.
I'm just gonna grab an extra bat just in case.
Oh my god, so many bats.
Oh my god.
Can someone hold...
Can someone hold this?
I have an issue.
The other one?
I'm holding one already.
Okay.
Hold the what?
Could actually someone swap me...
a purple bag?
Wait, I can hold this actually.
I can hold it.
I have a purple bag.
Yeah, can someone swap me?
Cause I'll probably be looting a lot of the boxes for us.
I don't know how to efficiently swap so everything's just gonna spill out.
Yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
Good.
I'm gonna make another medkit for us.
Yay!
Okay.
You can get into the car.
Alright.
Just gonna...
make sure... I have everything I need.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh wait, wait.
I'm fucking driving the car.
I can.
Woah!
What happened Spoons?
It's okay.
I guess it was better that I died.
We can die to zone by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot.
Wait, how many seconds do we have in zones again?
Uh, five minutes.
Five minutes?
Oh yeah, cause I remember someone probably died from zone.
Cool.
What a noob.
Was it your team?
It was a DSG.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Wait, hold up.
I'm gonna die to zone real quick.
So I can get a medkit.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I see the vision.
That's smart.
Okay, don't worry.
Anytime now.
Yep.
Mm-hmm.
For sure.
I'm getting a little scared.
Okay.
There you go.
I was also seeing the res timer.
Okay.
We'll go here.
Alright.
Yay.
There's a lot of people.
Whoa.
There's a team over there.
What the fuck?
I was gonna say how I fell down.
I'm gonna grab the armor here.
Got it?
Yep.
Perfect.
Let's go up here.
Alright.
Damn it.
Just a nice scenic ride.
I hope we get out of the door.
So great.
So 20 teams.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no.
I am stuck in the car.
I am...
What is going on?
Oh my god.
Just run.
We can res.
Yeah, I res.
I res.
But I got hit.
I got hit.
Yeah.
Tiffy.
Hold your knock.
Molly, I'm holding a Sykes.
Oh.
They came out of nowhere.
I got stuck in that car in the horizon.
They were ratting it.
I can't believe it.
We can land on the creeper.
It's okay.
We have all our stuff.
But they're also super stacked now.
Okay.
Maybe not on the creeper.
So I'll just look in.
Let's land.
Our perfect rotate.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
Yeah, we died on purpose so we can get a spot, right?
This may not be the right spot to go, but we'll go here.
There's a team right here.
Yeah.
I landed at the bottom.
Whoops.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm safe here, I think.
Yep.
Um.
Are you guys safe up there, though?
I think we're gonna drop down.
Drop down.
Yeah.
Let's go in here.
Play in here.
I'm fine.
I have ult in 50.
Yep.
Here's an extra med kit.
There's a phoenix kit right here.
If anyone wants it.
You okay?
Um.
It actually pulled across.
So let's follow me.
Okay.
We're gonna pray that this team does not hold us out.
But they have blue armor.
Wait.
Yeah.
We're gonna play.
We're gonna.
Yeah.
We're gonna play.
Oh.
51.
One has purple.
We're gonna play out here.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
I don't see anybody behind that team.
Yeah.
We're gonna fight at this building.
Alright.
I have ult here too.
We can hide.
There's another team going northwest.
And they're gonna fight them first.
Okay.
Let me just wait.
That's good.
Alright.
So we just hide.
We don't make presence.
Yeah.
I'll take this rock so you can't get us all.
I have ult too.
We need it.
I'll have ADE too right now.
Ooh.
This is a...
cannon ending.
Especially probably over here.
Wait.
I have evac.
Do we ever need to use it?
Yeah.
We're gonna pretty much go for these buildings and then we'll evac over.
Okay.
My guy is still 20 swats.
Oh no.
And Zona's gonna be hell.
Alright.
Follow me.
Behind you.
Don't shoot him.
Okay.
Keep walking.
Hug the wall.
Low walk up.
Yeah.
Over here.
I think they might have saw us but keep low.
Okay.
We're little rats.
Yeah.
Rats.
Okay.
Walk up.
I'm here.
We are hard to chill in here.
We're gonna sit right here.
Perfect.
No one will ever know.
Oh nice.
Careful of the window behind you.
Just hide in the corner.
Hello.
I'm here.
Perfect.
How far are you guys from your red?
I had 759.
Okay.
Oh my god.
A squad full died.
I think we climb up.
We're not 20th.
Yeah.
They're fighting.
We can look for this.
Okay.
Did they die?
Over here I see them.
Yeah.
They might have died.
Ring close in one minute.
I'm gonna see.
He's shooting.
He's looking back at us.
Does he know?
Does he know our existence?
I don't think he knows.
We're pretty much gonna follow behind them.
Okay.
Alright.
And they cleared the way for us.
Yeah.
Should be fine.
I'm just gonna hide.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh yeah.
We'll be fine.
We'll be hard chilling.
We'll be so chill.
Yeah.
We're gonna turn around.
This guy's looting the box until there's like literally nothing in it.
Yeah.
What is he gonna do?
Just stay there forever?
Until the zone kills him?
Don't turn around.
Okay.
Follow my pathing.
Try not to hit the traps.
I'm okay.
I'm gonna go and leave.
I'm gonna go and change the right here a little bit.
You ready to 3-2-1 this person in front of us?
Yeah.
They're right here.
Ready?
3-2-1.
Go.
Got him.
Plastic.
Nice.
Really good job.
Yep.
They're right here.
On me.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's a team with a Newcastle wall.
I have ult too.
We need to use it.
Newcastle right in the zone right here.
At this rock.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
Nice.
And then we play the wall.
Okay.
One of us.
They all died.
I think.
No.
Stay there.
Watch out.
Right?
Wait.
They did all die.
Oh.
They all died?
Do we take that spot?
No.
You stay there.
Watch the right side.
They're rotating.
Blue armor.
Blue armor on the C.
You can't be coordinated forever.
Also purple.
I'm gonna need energy ammo.
Is there any energy ammo over there?
To me?
Yes.
There is.
Okay.
Jarek.
Come to you or you taxi it over.
You will come to me in a second.
I'm gonna make sure that...
Oh.
Okay.
Team right up here too.
I'm going in.
Yeah.
They didn't come over here.
Nice.
Oh.
Might be on us.
We'll be okay.
We have this... Right here.
Right here.
Start shooting.
Start shooting so you guys can get red.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I got stuck.
Bro.
I'm missing my scout shots.
I'm just gonna grab some C if there's any other loot for me.
Okay.
Got red.
Nice.
We're gonna rotate here.
We're gonna rotate here really slow.
Okay.
I'm working.
I am like... I'm 100 away from red.
But I don't have anybody to shoot at right now.
Okay.
Cool.
You're behind this rock.
Oh.
This team here too.
Let me shoot you.
Oh.
I need to grab some light ammo and walk over to you guys.
Yeah.
There's a lot of light.
I don't think there's light.
You're gonna have to...
There is.
Here, here, here.
There's armors up in the back if you wanna grab the armor.
Thank you.
I'm 3% off from...
Oh shit, turn right, right.
Can you come here?
Yeah, let me know if I need to ult, conduit, ult, anything.
Yeah, can you conduit ult this up here?
We're gonna take the zip and go up.
Yep, nice.
Should I cross the gap?
Take the zip, take the zip, take the zip.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm taking it.
And then you're gonna ult right here, underneath the stairs.
Alright.
Woo!
Right underneath.
Yeah, right here is good.
Yeah, perfect.
Perfect.
Someone's taking damage red on top of us.
They have a caustic, they have a caustic.
We have to shoot the traps.
We can also play in here.
I nearly need like 45 left.
No, it was a mirage clone.
We can also play right here.
I got red, I got red.
Wait, wait, what the fuck?
The windows can see you.
Yeah, I got red.
I don't need to ult.
I'm not gonna worry now.
Nice.
20 seconds on my ult.
I mean, no, my shield.
Come to me, come to me, come to me.
Come to my side, my side, my side.
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
I'm getting ticked by caustic ult.
Yeah, I'm dead.
I can just crawl up to you.
There's a prison here, prison here.
Just try to beat me off of the...
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm watching.
Yeah, yeah, come back up.
Come back up.
We're super safe.
Alright, here you go.
You have your ult back?
Here, get your ult back.
52.
Alright.
Uh-oh.
Whoa, it's final zone.
I have another ult, excel too, if anyone wants it.
I can take, or do you have portal?
Yeah, I do have portal.
Okay, I'm popping it's ult, so...
Okay, what you're gonna do...
is I'm gonna I'm gonna port spoons.
What you're gonna do is you need to ult, okay?
You're gonna ult right here.
Where do I face?
Like, do I face this direction?
Do I face west?
No, no, no.
So ult right here, and then face towards the building.
Towards the building?
Okay, okay.
The building to our right, yeah.
So you're gonna ult right here.
Actually, let me ping you a little bit better.
More right here.
Right there is the winning spot.
So you can stay where I'm standing, and you ult right here.
And then I face the building.
The barrier faces the building.
Okay.
Do you want me to take portal with you right away?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here.
That's where you're gonna...
And then when you ult, please send your shield as well after your Q.
I'll ping it again for you so you know exactly where.
I feel like I'm gonna accidentally go into the portal.
No, no, no.
You're good.
Just stand on this, and then if you need to jump off, you'll be fine.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going now.
Ult right here.
Where I'm standing.
Ult right where I am.
Okay, ready?
Yep.
Right now, right now.
And then turn for the big thing.
Perfect, perfect.
Nice.
Put your Q, put your Q.
Should I ult?
Put your Q down, put your Q down.
Oh god, our armor thing is gone.
No!
I got it, I got you.
That's okay.
Put your Q down, put your Q down.
Put your shield.
Thank you.
Yep.
Put your shield, put your shield, shield, shield, shield.
Put your Q, put your Q, put your Q.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have to go up, I have to go up.
I couldn't.
I had to go up.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna try to break the caustic traps.
Oh no.
Holy shit.
Dang, they broke my caustic...
I mean... Oh my god, we got Fizz.
We got Fizz, let's go.
Oh, you said my shield.
Okay, when you said shield, I thought you meant conduit shield.
That's why I got so confused.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay, it's okay.
I was like, I was like, Spooze, why aren't you putting...
Why aren't you giving us the Q?
Yeah, yeah, honestly, I could've ported us in the spot that I went to.
But I feel like we might have died there.
I think our spot was maybe better.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that was a good spot.
Yeah, that was a good spot.
Yeah.
That was hard.
I was like, shield?
You mean conduit shield?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a Q, and then I was like shield, and I was like, hmm, it's still not coming down.
I know, you meant I didn't say anything.
Yeah, I was just like, when's the conduit shield?
That was good, we got fifth.
We got fifth, that's really good.
We also got five kills.
Yeah, kills don't matter though.
I think we should get a hundred for every kill.
Kill matters in our hearts.
Oh, it's duo's time.
Next round.
That's like $400, right?
Still?
I don't even remember how the prize ratings are done.
Um...
Whoa!
Wait, a thousand to a hundred?
Wait, do each of us get a thousand to a hundred?
It's split between three.
Oh!
Okay, I was gonna say ten.
That's the total.
400 bones.
Nice.
We're so close to 500.
God damn it, how?
This guy just can't let us win content creator tourneys either.
All good.
It's just greedy.
I know, right?
God damn.
Stop joining tourney.
You have enough money.
Alright, GG's guys.
GG's.
Good luck in your next game.
GG!
Likewise, thanks for playing.
Bye bye.
Alright, there's no team 22 voice chat so I'm waiting.
I can't believe the shield was me.
I was so confused.
I was just like, what do you mean?
I was just like...
I was just like, where's the conduit shield?
Where's the conduit...
I was like, don't worry guys.
I'm here.
I didn't realize it was...
I didn't realize it was my shield.
I got confused because conduit also uses shield.
I don't have a shield.
It's just a tomato brain moment.
I was like, here we go.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I was like, yeah, I got my ult down!
And then I was like, alright, I did my job.
The shields, what do they mean?
The shields!
What do the shields mean?
That's my streamer.
That's me!
I'm so fucking smart.
Alright, I need to look, read it up.
Read up the thing.
What do we need?
Oh, we got a new code.
Okay.
New code time.
New code.
My duo is dropped, by the way.
Drop will be my duo.
Uh... which one you two?
Oh, there it is.
Um...
That's my duo.
I'm gonna see if there's like any specific rules.
That...
It always... It's like a circle!
It's a circle!
Oh my god, he can IGL!
That's true!
I'm already a step up!
It comes full circle.
Alright, let's see.
There's no additional...
Oh, Gibby Caustic only!
Okay.
That's fine.
We can make this work.
There's only Gibby and Caustic.
It's not a circle, it's a spiral.
That's funny.
I can't believe I thought it was a Karnian cube.
I can't believe it.
I was just like, where is my cube?
Where is it?
What do you mean?
I was like, God damn it, Spoons!
Where the fuck is my Karnian cube?
It's gonna haunt me for the rest of my life.
Hey, I still got top 5!
I still got top 5.
It's still something.
Chat.
We still...
Cube is in our heart.
No!
The thing is Karnian also does shields!
That's why I got confused!
I thought...
I was like, that's a weird plan.
That's a weird plan.
Put down my ult and then a Karnian cube?
I was like, that's weird.
Cuz he's like, Q Q Q.
I was like, Karnian cube?
Everything was...
in the heat of the moment.
He never said which cube.
Yeah, that's true.
Look, I need my hand to be held for IGLing, okay?
Like, they have to be very fucking specific or I would be very fucking confused for the rest of my time.
Like, I need people to be extremely specific in what they mean.
That's why.
Okay guys, it's not my fault.
Chat.
It's not my fault.
They have to be incredibly specific.
People need to like... people need to make sure they illiterate...
uh... what was it?
They have... I'm illiterate, but so...
People need to be very, very specific.
Alright, we're just waiting for it.
We're just waiting for it dropped and then we should be good to go.
We're waiting for it dropped to join in.
It's...
Yeah, yeah.
My streamer moment.
Look guys, I'm the content creator here, okay?
You can't assume that my brain would be fine tuned the same way as all the other actual Apex players.
I'm a content creator.
This is my duo.
Dropped.
That's him.
So like, it's not my fault.
The content creator debuffed chat.
It was sadly the content creator debuff.
It's a...
Yeah, these are really stacked players.
Yeah.
I mean, the first game we got Jen.
Second game we got Timmy.
Third game we got dropped.
That's actually really lucky for us.
Wait, he's not here.
Wait, what do I play?
He's not...
He's not even in voice chat!
What do I play?
I don't know!
We're starting!
He's AFK?
Wait, he plays Gibby.
He's known for Gibby, right?
I'm Kosti.
Yo, what do you wanna play?
Oh shit!
Okay!
Kosti, we're here!
Okay.
Alright.
Where the fuck were you?
We didn't even strategize!
I was grabbing food.
I had to grab food.
You grabbed food?
Was it worth it?
Yeah.
What was it worth to get?
I have an 8.
What did you get though?
I got chicken and rice.
You got chicken...
That's what you ditched?
Chicken and rice?
Mmhmm.
That's like the most plain ass shit ever!
You ditched a very important tournament by the way.
This has more money than Pro League and you ditched that for chicken and rice?
Wait, what is our drop spot?
Launch site.
Okay.
Technically you're not wrong.
It does have more money than Pro League.
Yeah!
I was gonna say!
Alright, let me raise your volume up a little bit.
So like, what's the strat here?
I don't know.
I mean, I'm just gonna play it how we like how a normal game does.
I don't think it's gonna be any different.
It's not gonna be any different?
Alright.
We might have a team that wants to come to us.
Oh, we're getting conned?
Maybe, yeah.
We're just gonna land here.
Okay.
If a team lands here try and like push out here and kill them.
Okay, no problem.
I don't know if anybody landed near us.
I don't see anyone.
I think we're good.
We're good?
Nice.
Nothing ever goes wrong for us.
It's off to a good start.
There's a hemlock there next to that if you need.
Uh, yeah.
I dropped a Havoc.
I heard Havoc is good this season.
Wait, zipping up towards the south.
What the fuck?
What are you doing there?
Leave!
So there is a team.
Alright, so go.
It might start peeking out of the glass.
Alright, I'm gonna go right.
Move right and steal all this loot.
Alright.
These guys are gonna have like literally nothing.
If you see a shotgun, let me know.
Like a Mastiff would be huge.
Alright, alright, alright.
And we got an Evo Harvester here.
We're gonna have Blues.
We can literally roll these guys.
I have an Ulti I can use that right now.
Do I want the throw?
Oh, here's a PK.
Do I want the throw range or the residual toxins?
The vision.
The vision?
Okay.
Oh, there's a Mastiff.
Nice.
I'm gonna drop PK.
Oh, and that?
I'm juiced.
You need bats?
I have three bats.
I got two.
Oh no, I didn't see him.
They're pushing.
I cracked him.
I cracked Nibby.
No, I dropped behind you.
No, I didn't see him.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Dang, that sucked.
That sucked.
So was it worth it?
Food to chicken or rice?
Was it...
Was the chicken or rice worth it?
What is it?
Oh man.
I can't believe it.
My first game where I died not top 10.
I'm lucky.
GG's though.
That was a...
I don't think that was like even...
That was a quick one.
Yeah, that wasn't even one minute.
I don't think so.
Hey, at least that's a hundred dollars.
You know?
That's one way to look at it.
Yeah, yeah.
It basically paid off your chicken or rice.
Uh huh.
A lot of chicken and rice actually.
Yeah, a lot of... yeah.
At least you...
It's alright.
We look at the positives here.
It's okay.
As long as it's more than pro league.
That's all that matters.
We got the participation.
Alright.
I'm gonna eat my food.
GG's though.
GG's.
Good luck in your next game too.
Good luck.
Guys, I don't think it's worth the chicken or rice.
I don't think it was worth this chicken and rice guys.
I don't...
I don't think the chicken and rice was worth it.
I didn't see them too.
I'm so fast.
But hey, the food.
The food's though.
Thanks, Mehdi.
Thanks guys.
Guys, I gotta play one minute with DropGaz.
I gotta play...
That's all that matters.
That's all...
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That actually was the fastest game ever.
The worst part is that it's duos.
So I have to wait even longer cause there's more people.
I think that's the worst part.
There's more people.
So I have to wait longer.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Now we're gonna...
We're gonna be nice.
We're gonna commentate.
We're gonna...
I'll never forgive chicken and rice.
I'll never forg... This... Oh!
Yes!
This is the perfect time to share!
By the way, guys!
By the way!
Guys!
I got sponsored by Gamersubs!
I'm an official partner of Gamersubs!
Chat!
Okay, let me like turn down the volume.
Let me...
Okay.
Yes!
I am an official Gamersubs partner now!
Chat!
Okay, maybe not all the way down.
Like I need some ambience here.
Um...
But!
Not only... Okay, wait.
I should... Okay.
Please!
Officially a Gamersubs partner use Doki Bird for 10% off all purchases.
This is a great time.
I died early so I can...
I can chill.
I died!
Okay.
Guys.
So what that means is that...
I not only have a code but also... So like if you use the code... Obviously like... Obviously because I'm sponsored I get...
Using the code really helps a lot for me.
And also!
I will have an official Gamersubs cup!
It's called a waifu cup.
That would be the only...
I don't know.
It's called a waifu cup but it's basically a... You know like the cup to use to put your Gamersubs in.
Or you know hold water or anything.
It's like a Stanley cup.
But better.
But cheaper.
You know?
But not... It's like a Stanley cup but like not over... What was it called?
Not over...
What's the word called?
When it's like over height?
What's that word called?
There's a specific word for it.
So better.
Yes.
Of course it's better.
It's gonna have my face on it.
No!
Let off a free game first!
Oh yeah.
Not overrated.
Exactly.
Goodbye Stanley Cup sponsors.
But if Stanley Cup wants to sponsor me as well.
If Stanley Cup wants to sponsor me as well, they're not overrated.
But they are currently because I'm sponsored by Gamersubs.
Anyway.
Uh...
What was I saying?
Oh yeah.
There's gonna be...
There's gonna be an art contest.
That's gonna start next week.
And basically whoever wins the art contest will have their art on my waifu cup and also win some prize money.
Uh... It was originally...
Gamersubs originally sponsored 5k for the art contest.
Rules will be given on April 5th on how to submit.
Uh... But Gamersubs originally...
This is all paid by Gamersubs by the way.
They put out 5k for the art contest.
But I wanted to choose more people.
So I added like 2k out of my own pocket because I want to be able to pay for more art.
Like... Because you know guys I feel like you guys are gonna submit so many beautiful art.
And I want to be able to compensate as many artists as I can.
So I decided to pay 2k out of my own pocket to add to the prize pool.
So it went from 5k to 7k.
Uh... Just so I could be able to pick more artists.
But only one artist will be on the cup.
Only one artist will be on the cup.
Um...
And...
Uh... Yes!
So yes.
Using my code helps out a lot.
Uh... It really does.
And it's on every purchase.
All purchase.
And everything.
So like anything you want to buy just use my code.
You get 10% off.
Um...
And... Uh... GamerSupps actually sent me like a package of their stuff.
Like a bunch of... Like they sent me like $300 worth of GamerSupps products for free.
To try them out and everything.
And like... Um... As you guys know I love free stuff.
So...
Also my froleg!
Oh my god!
My mod...
My mod is a better streamer than I am.
Let me... I didn't even remember I had a referral link.
I'm sorry GamerSupps.
I actually did not remember.
Guys!
Give me a sec.
I also have a referral link by the way!
Guys let me...
Let me grab the referral link real quick.
Chat.
Uh...
Guys you guys know so much more.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay here we go.
I'm gonna re-pin this.
I'm gonna re-pin this real quick.
Uh...
Here we go.
Guys use my referral link too.
Thank you much!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
But anyway as I was saying.
Uh...
They sent me...
I get to try a lot of flavors.
Um... I didn't get to try all of them yet.
But like... I think they're all...
I think they're really liked so far.
Is the melon one.
The melon one's really nice.
I really like the melon flavor.
And there was like one more that I also like but I don't remember what it was called.
It was... uh...
I think it was the peach one.
The melon and the peach one were...
were really good.
I haven't tried every one.
Look guys.
I was sent $300 worth of products.
I was not...
I... I...
I did not have a lot of time to try out the rest.
There were a lot.
I didn't have time to try out all of them.
But peach and melon were currently my favorites so far.
Out of all the ones I was able to try.
Of all of them I was able to try, peach and the melon... the peach and melon one was pretty good.
Um... other than that... let's see.
I'm trying to think.
What else I need to show?
Uh... but yes!
Look forward to the art contest!
Look forward to the art contest and I'm really really excited.
There's also a lot of really good back to back news later on.
So maybe more stuff being announced later on.
So...
Um... I'm trying to make sure to like not overwhelm you guys too much with everything.
Because there is a lot of news.
So...
I'm trying my best to like not overwhelm you guys.
Yes!
My... Scars Cup!
I got invited to my first JP tournament!
As Doki!
That's really... um...
I don't know if I can tell you who my teammates are.
I already know who my teammates are.
Uh...
But like they can speak English.
So... um... so like...
That's all I can say.
But I don't know...
who... if I can... I mean that sort of like... tells you who my teammates are.
Because like there's not...
like...
Because like... um... it like limits... I guess it like...
narrows down the participants of who they are.
So...
Yes!
That narrows a lot of people!
It narrows down a lot of people in JP!
In general!
So... like teammates can speak... can communicate in English with me.
So I won't be... you know...
So I won't be like a hazard!
Hahaha!
Um...
But yes!
I will be participating in my first... uh... Japanese tournament.
Um... It has a lot of like...
insane gamers out there.
Like... you know... like there's like... this tournament there's a lot of like... professional players here.
Um... It's like one professional player and two content creators.
Basically per team.
And...
And... uh...
And I'm gonna... uh... and like... I think it is on...
Tappy's in it!
Tappy's in there!
Our... our Apex Oshi!
Hahaha!
He'll forever be my Apex Oshi!
Because of the smile!
Hahaha!
Our Apex Oshi won Tappy!
I... I... sorry... that... that emote is like... honestly my favorite.
Um... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Someone post a smile so we can copy and paste it.
Tappy our Apex Oshi!
Uh... But yes!
I think that is all the news I can...
I have announced.
Karaoke has been rescheduled to... You know I can even tell you guys my schedule right now.
Um... I finalized my schedule.
Next week I'll be taking three rest days.
Technically it's three rest days.
Um... due to everything that's going on.
Uh... so...
I have Shadow of Colossus.
Shadow of Colossus on Monday.
Um...
Snuffy collab on Wednesday.
Snuffy is gonna tour...
She's gonna tour...
Fucking...
Hahaha!
Snuffy is gonna give me a tour on Roblox.
She was very excited about that.
She was...
She was like...
Oh my god!
What have you...
Can I tour... give you like...
Show you all my favorite Roblox servers?
And I was like...
You know what?
I'm down.
Okay to be fair at first we were like...
Oh my god!
We should do Warrior Cats cause like in the past we actually really wanted collab in the past and do like...
A Warrior Cats RP server on Roblox.
Because Warrior Cats official server...
Warrior Cats has an official Roblox...
Uh... server.
Hahaha!
And like we've always wanted to do that.
But we never got the perms to do it.
So then...
We were like... Oh my god!
It...
Is it time?
Are we finally gonna do our Warrior Cats RP...
Roblox collab?
And then Snuffy was like... Oh my god!
Can I give you a tour on Roblox?
Can I show you like...
All my favorite Roblox servers?
And I was like... You know what?
Fuck it!
Let's... Give me the tour!
Give me... Give me...
The tour!
So...
We're gonna have a...
We're gonna have a Roblox collab together.
Um...
On Wednesday.
And then I think...
After that... Um...
It's karaoke on Friday.
And then...
Uh... Scar's Cup.
I think...
No Scar's Cup!
Sorry!
Scar's Cup first.
And then karaoke later on.
I think like Scar's Cup is like at 2 in the morning.
And then...
Oh!
Okay!
Wait!
The team I spectate died.
When did they die?
I don't even remember they died.
Okay!
Anyway!
After that...
Scar's Cup at 2 in the morning.
Karaoke at 5.
And then... The day after that...
It's Challenger Circuit with Wig and Tempo.
And I hope to fucking... I hope to fucking god that...
Uh...
I... I...
I...
I hope it's not 7 hours.
I really hope it's not 7 hours.
I'm just...
You know when Tempo told me it's a 7 hour long day.
I thought he meant like overall.
But then... But then he was like...
No!
It's just for one day.
I was like... What?
And then Wig...
And then Wig was like... Okay.
But theoretically...
Only if we make it to the next day.
So like... It's all... It's all about like you know... Making it to the next day and stuff.
So like theoretically...
There's a chance that we get eliminated early.
So like... Let's hope to...
No!
We're gonna do our best!
We're gonna do our best chat.
We're gonna... We're gonna try our best here.
We're not gonna fuck around.
Oh yeah!
I'll also be playing off stream with Tempo and Wig.
They might be streaming it.
I might... I'm not.
I already have two Apex streams next week.
So...
I was just like... I'm just gonna play off stream with them.
Yeah.
So... We're gonna try our best here.
Okay chat?
I think that's everything!
Is that everything?
I think so.
I think that is everything I have to announce.
Mod, have I missed anything?
Mod?
Did I miss anything?
See you in rank.
Yeah we're gonna...
We're gonna... I'm gonna be playing rank on...
on Wig's stream.
I'm pretty sure he's gonna be streaming.
He streams every fucking day.
Almost.
Uhhh...
Anything else?
Is everything good to go?
I'm gonna check if they announced game 4 yet.
What is game 4?
We have 3 more games.
Oh!
30 versus 30!
There's no way I can drag down my team!
There's no way I can drag down 29 other people.
Hahahaha!
There's 30 versus 30 people.
There's surely... surely...
I can...
Uh...
Oh!
Last week to pre-order the Lunar New Year merch!
By the way!
This is the last week to pre-order the Lunar New Year merch chat.
Umm... We have one more week left.
We have one more week for Lunar New Year merch.
Umm... People who ordered the buttons and stickers might... only the buttons and stickers might receive them earlier because I actually received the stickers before anything else.
So...
You might receive your stickers umm... Only for people who ordered stickers.
Only the... only the people who only ordered the stickers and the buttons.
Cause umm... They separated the delivery and I received the stickers first.
So...
So the other stuff will take a while to arrive.
The other stuff...
will still take quite a bit to arrive to us.
When does everything else ship out?
Umm... Most likely...
May... May or June.
Most likely.
It's around May or June.
Umm... The reason being is that the products are shipped via...
a fucking giant boat.
Like I take... I...
I use the ocean to ship my products because there's a lot of them.
And like...
My air was really fucking expensive.
Like yeah!
I may receive them in like...
2-3 weeks.
But...
Uhh... There were a lot of them.
By air...
It was a lot of them.
So like...
It was easier to just do it by cargo and by ship.
Wait... Who won?
Yeah... It's gonna go... It's gonna deliver by... by a boat.
So that's why it's gonna take a bit to get here.
Like... It was literally...
Like if I chose plain option...
It would have been like...
If I chose the plain option...
It would have been... It would have been so fucking expensive.
Like it would have been like... half the...
It would have been like half the price of the merch.
And I was like...
I was just like... What the fuck?
I was like... Nah...
Fuck that.
Holy shit.
I do not need that.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where are we?
Where's... Where's Joki?
Where's the... Are we in red or blue?
I'm blue.
I'm with Noddy and Doll.
Noddy... Noddy's a roller player!
Right?
I need to brush up on my Apex Pro player.
Um... Apex Pro.
Noddy.
Uh...
Wait.
Right?
Or is he my... Yes!
Battle Beaver!
I knew it.
God.
Knew it.
My... My first ro... Wait.
No.
It wasn't drop... Is drop roller?
I don't remember.
I actually don't... I don't remember my Apex Pro player lore.
It's been way too long.
I don't remember my...
Oh yeah.
Jen.
Jen was roller.
Yeah, but we were fucking punching people.
That doesn't count.
It doesn't count because we were punching people.
Okay.
You can use what you want but you have to stick with your team.
Has the drops for both sides.
For a match you spend to figure out which team gets which class.
The winning team.
Whatever.
Uh... Hal.
I leaked the code.
Okay guys.
We're gonna get random people joining in because Hal accidentally leaked the code.
Yeah we're...
I leaked the code.
Alright.
I hope he didn't actually.
You said he was gonna do that.
Wait.
What?
What the hell?
Alright.
It's okay.
You guys gotta rewind the time.
I'm gonna find it.
Did he actually?
I can't tell if he was fucking around.
If we did.
If he did.
People would fucking join in right now.
Alright.
I'm trying to see what's the next option.
Let's see.
Uh...
We are in...
This is game 4 drop.
What the fuck is this?
Are we C or A?
My brain is...
My brain.
Okay.
I think it didn't help that I woke up 30 minutes before this stream.
I took a nap.
I took...
I took a nap before.
Okay.
We are assault.
Then which one's controller?
Wait.
This map is so confusing.
We're assault.
Okay.
We got...
What the fuck is that?
Yellow is no man's land.
You cannot go in there until you see an admin type star in game What the fuck?
This is actually.
I thought we're gonna be like playing controller something.
I thought.
Okay.
So we're playing storm point.
And we're going on the side on the right.
What is my team number?
We got a new code guys.
He actually did leaked it.
I thought it was a joke.
But he did it.
That madman.
He actually did it.
I thought he was just fucking around.
Our CEO guys.
Alright.
Let's see.
Format.
What's the next other games?
Five and six.
Five and six is three strikes again.
And then punching again.
So this is a lot.
Okay.
So team five is also three strikes.
We are with team sixteen.
Alright.
Team sixteen.
Let's see.
That's our CEO.
The thing that does free content.
Let's see.
Sixteen.
Hello.
Hi.
Let's go.
Alright.
What are we playing?
We have like...
Yeah.
But like what legends are we doing?
Oh assault.
So anyone from the assault.
Oh shit.
That's what it meant.
Oh.
I was so confused.
I was like what does that even mean?
I was like...
Hey guys.
I'm the content creator here on this team.
As you can tell.
As you kids can tell.
The only times I play Apex is when I get invited.
Alright.
So what...
Are we supposed to be in like separate discords or all together in one?
Well we can...
Let me see.
We can do all... Oh I think we're doing all together.
Sorry.
It's like a choice.
You can either be in one voice chat which I think you know 30 people in a voice chat is a little bit fucked up.
Or you can like join together in like your own team voice.
Oh my god.
Is the team six?
What is going on there?
Team six is the controller team.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out who's who though.
Like if that's the other team or if that's us.
No that's the other team.
Cause like Hal's in there.
So Hal's on the controller side.
So like...
You can tell that our team is very corny.
Our team...
No one's taking control over here.
I can tell that...
Start telling everyone to move to 13.
Yeah I think it's 13.
Go 13.
Oh 13?
Okay.
No...
I don't want all of us in the same voice.
I'm muted.
I'm muted myself guys.
Y'all if you see an assault character don't kill them.
Don't shoot each other.
What are the assault characters?
What if we just...
What if we just 30 men and one building.
We're going against controllers.
But okay.
One of us out of the 30 of us should know where zone is right?
At least a little.
That's the whole point.
If we get to the building first we win.
I think Timmy's onto something.
Okay lowkey that might work.
Yo it's Timmy is cooking so bad.
And then imagine like we all got a Maggie and we all drill in them too.
Boss?
No team?
No Diddy.
Wrong game.
It's a party now.
I'm just nervous for all the rollers.
Like Timmy's saying don't kill the controller.
Don't shoot our assault characters.
My aim assist is about to go crazy.
My aim assist is about to pull us.
Wait MNK up right now.
I forgot MNK is up.
Yo MNK it's off now.
Simmer down.
Just make sure we calm like really really hard this game.
Should we have all the asses?
Should we at least have one Maggie on every team by the way?
I feel like Cry and aim assist.
Like imagine Maggie fuse.
Oh my god we're gonna be...
I mean if we all have Bangled and then we have zone we just Bangled them and they can't cross.
Yeah and then they put Watson on them.
One Ashe on the team so we can all use the one teleport.
Nah it'll be fine.
We can just pick the Jhin.
I already have Ballistic so we just all insta-rayload.
Does it work for everybody?
Bro Nauti literally left our...
Nauti is like...
Nauti is like crashing somebody else's VC.
He's not even in this one.
Bro what the fuck.
I got peer pressure due to this.
Nauti literally fucking joined some other VC.
He's not even with us.
What the fuck is this bullshit.
I sucked it up.
We have one single Ashe.
So we're drilling people now.
What if we have three teams.
Three teams are Ashe and then they just fucking...
They're like the secret agents and shit.
Yeah they're like the power rangers.
Who's the best rat out of all of us?
Me.
Is that...
This is so awkward.
Bro this is so fucking awkward man.
This is so...
Oh yeah.
What map is it?
And we're on the east side.
Too many cooks.
We got mills and downed beasts.
I can't tell if it's gonna go...
I think we're on the east side.
We have to go right.
We wanna make sure to split it.
Bro all the controller pros.
All the controller pros.
Like fucking left us.
They're in their own voices.
This is so fucked up.
Naughty joined the controller pros voice chat.
Bro what the fuck.
What?
There's like Naughty, Sykes, Zynu, and Pho.
And like they're all in their own fucking voice chat.
Let's do two lightning rods, two Zeus.
One command.
Probably one storm.
I think one...
We should go cascade balls.
And then they can go towards Jurassic.
We should have one team launch pad.
One team loot the bridge up high.
And then they can go pylon.
And then one Devastate and one Echo.
Alright good.
Wait wait wait.
How are we assigning this to everybody?
I'm just gonna say team 14 will take stormcatcher.
Cause that's our team.
Say what you wanna do.
Inus just said team 11 to 20 left side of map.
Oh what?
Left side of map?
See?
I think for voice call as well though.
Should we have like two teams per voice call?
So we don't clutter everyone?
No.
Or you wanna just like all do our comms in here?
We don't have to like just ping and game.
Don't...
I don't know I wouldn't want to comm in here.
Oh light mag like 50% saying it.
That is so weird.
Res me or push this guy at the building.
That is weird.
Like initially...
Everybody just point at your monitor.
Point at your monitor?
Point at your monitor.
Just point him out.
Don't cross.
I think I didn't left side call.
I didn't left side or right side.
Cause then you will finish them please.
Holy crap.
Can this work?
I'm writing something for you guys.
What if I just join the other voice chat?
Nice.
Oh bet.
So I'll go on launchpad.
Perfect.
That's all I need to know.
Yeah that's fine.
Not delete it so they don't find...
They don't get the strategy.
There's no command on that list.
So could have team 11.
That is so helpful.
And then pylon's 11 command.
Yeah.
Let me see how many cars are there.
Fang, Fuse and Magi right?
Where do we all want to meet up at?
Alright so we're...
Oh pylon's...
This is so chaotic.
We should most likely group up at...
Drop can you start doing some IGL calls?
Oh you want me to fucking...
Pipe up?
Pipe up.
Bing, Mad, Magi, Fuse.
We need to divvy up where people are going.
We haven't.
Our IGL isn't even with us!
We need a new commander.
Our commander is lost already.
Our pro player IGL isn't even in this bullshit!
I'm down for 10 years.
He fucking left us with the other controller pros!
I changed 11 to 12 for command because pylon's not in.
Bro you fucking joined the controller pro side!
So one time, where are we all landing?
Look at tournament chat.
Make sure you pick your characters.
What is Lottie?
I guess I'll do Mad Magi.
I'm in the lobby.
I'm looking at the lobby.
Oh, someone already DC'd.
Am I have to restart?
Wait, who's too loud?
I don't even know who's too loud!
There's 30 people!
They're gonna restart.
They'll probably restart.
Okay, I turned it down.
Guys, the thing is, I don't even know who's too loud.
There's 30 people in here!
I can't even tell!
They're not restarting.
Not restarting?
Oh, there they are.
They're not restarting.
I'm gonna put the voice chat on fail.
It's kinda scuffed.
I'm not gonna lie, this is...
I'm kinda getting over-stimulated.
Guys, you know this server definitely does not have any boosts right now.
Once he's put start...
Pylon?
Oh yeah.
We all move at pylon?
Yeah, once he types start.
Nah, I don't think everyone, but I feel like the bottom side of the map teams should all move there and then group up.
And then we need to like, group up.
I mean, we don't know where the zone's gonna be, right?
Cause there's gonna be zones.
You can tell this server is boostless.
I say we wait until the zone closes and then we decide to go somewhere else.
Yeah, I mean, I think in general we should probably just group up or half go Cascades, half go Pylon and then we can just meet in the middle.
We're also outgoing Zeus, by the way.
We also have dogs on that north side that is available.
So...
One of you guys should do that.
Oh, yeah.
That's all available to us.
Yeah.
Yo, you think I'm breaking the rules from standing outside the line at command?
I hit that spider that's in the line?
Just fight spiders without crossing the line?
Yeah.
Make the spiders come to you.
I feel like we need a hard rail height I feel like we need a hard rail height like, on everything.
I do want to also point out, we probably should have roughly 30-30 snipers they have rampart walls so we do need to break those.
You have rampart walls?
What the fuck?
Why didn't they get the gook side?
We're not fusing.
We're just spamming at the rampart walls.
I...
If...
Why didn't we get rampart?
Is that fair?
Oh, no.
People DC'd.
Scrims.
Again.
Please.
Oh my god.
Get the 30-30 game out of my life faster.
You might just give her every hit at that point.
So is the voice better?
I lowered the volume.
Is it better now?
No, play Ash.
Oh my god.
If somebody wants to be quirky and play Ash...
Is the volume better now?
There you go.
I'll be a little lower.
That's the new code, right?
Has to be.
Why is this game the one that is the hardest to start?
This is the game that I'm most uncomfortable with because there's too many people.
My introvert ass can't handle this.
I'm gonna repost our thing.
I'm gonna post it too.
Thank you.
My introvert ass can't handle this.
It's too many cooks.
Suffering.
Please.
Is it not a new code?
My social battery is gone already.
How were you?
Too many cooks.
No, I'm just loading back.
It didn't get me the second time, but...
I'm gonna go relay the information to our other peoples.
I'm picking a bright orange Ash skin so everyone knows.
Okay.
Oh my god, we're coordinating our skins to a color?
How cute would that be?
That would be something.
That would be...
We need people going bean, by the way.
What the fuck is bean?
Is it... is it Cascade Balls?
Balls, yeah.
I'm so confused.
That whole, like, those buildings on the south.
North of Pylon.
We could have another team from Command Center go down there.
You know what's funny, chat?
The other side, the other chat, all of them are like united and together.
And then there's our team or the controller players literally left into their own voice chat.
Like...
Oh yeah, the thing you listed, by the way, of two teams, I feel like one of those teams needs to be...
That's really funny.
Our team, the controller players, don't even want to be together with us.
Like, that's our team.
No, not my voice.
The other team is like, our team, the mouse and keyboard players, and the roller players are united together.
One from Command Center.
Probably one of the Command teams.
Team 12, Cascade Balls.
You mean Team 11?
I just thought it was so funny.
I never knew it was called that.
It's literally all the roller players, too.
Like, what the f...
They're just like, we're outta here.
And someone from the loose needs to do that.
Wait, we don't know.
Nevermind.
Are these guys...
Are they stealing our shot right now?
No, we gave them time.
I think we're just waiting on Red to connect.
Wait, did Drop leave to see the controller gang?
It's not even controller.
What are you doing here?
Get out.
Drop, leave their voice chat!
You're not even part of that group!
I don't think they will.
Drop left to check on the controller gang.
What if we just have all the controller players go to one side and then the MEK players go to the other side?
Oh, they came back.
Drop came back.
What if we diviate the controller players?
Put one in their center spot.
What if we divide the role?
The controller players go stand in the corner.
Use them as bait.
I mean, they're already doing that.
Don't worry, I'm plugging in the keys right now.
They're already doing that.
You got a turret.
Stop becoming one of you.
MadMaggie time.
Welcome to the dark side.
I don't know what the strat is.
I'm just gonna play the game.
I'm just gonna play!
This is so scary.
I don't even know what the strat is.
I tuned out the strat.
Which is pretty bad.
I should not have tuned out.
I have no idea where we're going.
King Digi.
Let's go because we got hostiles.
Let's go.
We're going launch pad.
Bullet tickets at command center.
Guys, no!
I can't be the first one in this team to die!
There's 30 of us!
I can't loot back side.
I'm out.
I'm gonna start from the front.
I'm gonna loot front of storm point.
Or storm catcher.
Wait, what are the other assault tanks?
I need to look it up.
I'm really confused.
Ash, Fuse, Mad Maggie, Bangalore, Rev.
Okay.
If I fuck up, it's not my fault.
I got overwhelmed.
I'm gonna follow Nadi.
I'm gonna loot back here.
Our pro player is not even with us.
I'm here.
Who am I looking at with their nice little sword?
Our pro player is not even in our chat.
He left us.
Oh my god, I almost killed him.
Okay.
They got zoned.
What the fuck?
Somebody code net.
Bro.
That's fucked up.
That's really bad.
What?
They have red pipes.
You see the rocks and shit over there?
They nearly have red pipes.
They have plastic barrels.
We're just gonna flank them.
Go all the way this side.
We're just gonna hit a hot flank.
I need a backpack.
Bro, we might as well cross the nomad's land.
We might as well cross the nomad's land.
At this point...
They got full on.
If you guys need like specific loot with your team, you should probably just type in game if it's possible.
That's probably the best way.
Yeah, or even just use voice chat.
Or voice chat, yeah.
Wait, did I steal somebody's loot?
I might have.
Wait, no.
We got... this is my loot now.
Oh my god, we're so fucking stupid.
Are we starting already?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
We have to just chill, I think.
Honestly, I think we just...
We have to go.
...fucking log shed right now.
I'll jive, I'll jive.
I'm about to go all the way up towards the wall.
IGLs, where do you want us to go?
IGLs.
Where should we meet?
We should meet Cascades.
Maybe we rotate late, get all the harvesters, get our shits on.
Yeah, I'm down.
We need to get all our harvesters, but fuck.
Yeah, we need to all get our armors up.
Try and focus getting evil harvesters.
I'm gonna do those command spiders.
You guys should split up and send each guy different harvesters.
Yeah.
Where's Nottie going?
It's a unit.
The IGL unit.
They're gonna be sitting behind walls for sure.
I don't wanna get triple shot on.
What do they say?
Do we think Banks should take ultimate cooldown or tap cooldown?
I think ult would go crazy right now.
Ult cooldown, yeah.
That's our teammate, right?
Yeah, they're on our side.
But if you die, probably mute so the people alive won't get confused.
Oh, thank god.
Makes sense.
You should just stop calling out while you're down.
Just rage really hard.
Start screaming you're holding knockdown.
Guys, I could've put the descript list of all the people that's in our voice.
Wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
Why is this guy shooting at us?
Bro, is it... Do we can...
There's a stupid Bang right there.
Wait, we can farm armors off them, can't we?
Did any of you guys loot walls?
No.
How does this round work?
We have to cross to the other side.
We have to cross here.
We should shoot each other.
We should shoot each other for Evo.
Oh!
Nice!
That was mine!
But then we're just wasting...
We're gonna lose our shields.
Just wasting our time.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's actually smart as fuck.
Wait, they're watsing too, so they get to spam it.
They're dumbed out.
What do we want?
Wrecking Ball?
Catch a spy?
Okay, Wrecking Ball.
And one of the...
Whose car is this?
That's us.
Are you back?
I'm with you on your left, Ren.
I'm looking for...
I'm looking for juice for us.
Yo, pylon is still unlooted, guys.
Yeah, I'm going to pylon her now.
We can do like the animal PLIs real quick too, or whatever the...
Oh yeah.
Yeah, it's probably important we get those for attachment.
I'm literally like tuning out what they're saying and just following Naughty right now.
I...
That's my strat.
I'm gonna believe in the controller.
I think they're all group.
In the controller squad.
I'm gonna shoot in pylon right now.
Just make sure...
Yeah, you're good bro.
We're in pylon.
The council of IGL.
Yo, I'm cast guys at the moment.
There's too many people.
Too many cooks.
What's up?
Anyone Jurassic?
No, we're in Jurassic.
We're in Jurassic.
We're at barometer.
What?
I like nothing.
I have nothing on my nemesis.
We should have been better on them.
Too many cooks.
That's not fair.
They would have gone to hide in the corner really quick.
We should have had the map with no zones.
In my opinion, we should honestly start grouping now and go kill them because they are 100% running around the map trying to get their evas up.
We should try to pick them.
What spot are we regrouping at?
Barrow you think?
I just saw two of them just waste evac.
So they're coming.
We should go to mill right now.
We should all go towards mill and try to kill people at mill.
Bro, the mill is so far.
Give us time though.
Is that one of us that hit Kennen?
Damn.
That's us.
Look at us go.
Where's the cascades?
The IGL council has arrived.
Oh my god, the mad Maggie council.
We should have just gone towards check point and then going towards Mill now.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm going to be really mad.
We should have flanked it.
We can probably take Godrock island or something.
Aight, bullets to Diash.
You're talking about which side of the map?
We should come from the north side.
If we go mill side.
If we go mill then we can go Godrock and then we can scout it.
Take this island?
I'm gonna go Godrock.
That's everything I registered.
We're in C2.
I'm gonna see where C2 is as well.
That's everything I could register from this 30 man chat.
Nevermind, let's just go.
We're walking over.
Are you going Milfs?
Yeah, we're gonna go Milfs.
Oh my god, what the fuck is this zone?
What the fuck is this zone?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Why did he get everything?
I have a balloon.
We can all rotate with a balloon.
Oh!
Oh, this can fucking take the balloon.
We should keep going towards Milfs side.
Yeah.
I'm gonna... I'm just...
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Let's all take the balloon.
Crafting time.
Crafting time!
One at a time, everybody!
There's gunshots in checkpoint.
Who's in checkpoint?
Where's Dotty?
She's shooting spiders.
I see him on the God Rocker now.
Oh, Dotty's behind us!
Oh my god.
This is a bad zone.
We can't use any bang-alls.
They're all the way over there.
We go C-Note then, right?
No one's guarding the left side of C-Note, are you?
The far left side entrance is C-Note.
We should probably group up, no?
Towards Barrow, right?
Going Bean?
Yeah.
Go Bean.
Like a... Bean?
I have a 2x4.
Nuddy, where are you going?
We probably need to wait for a bunch of people too.
There's no one holding the side.
Yeah, let's do it.
Which side are you talking about?
We're going beans.
Oh, he's getting the armor.
Left side of Ceno.
We're on our way.
I'm going to go too.
I don't want to be like...
Get in.
I'm waiting for you guys.
Is that people there?
Is that them?
Yeah, that's them.
I'm in Cenote now.
Yeah, we're moving up.
Nobody close buildings.
So you guys are at Mills?
We're good at Mills.
We're going bean right now.
We're moving into Ceno.
I'm waiting for you guys.
We should probably just group up here and wait for everyone.
On the main hill.
Yeah.
Are you allowed to take care packs then?
I'm so scared.
I don't see anybody.
Oh, I see them.
Look at their fucking shoes.
We're going through.
We're going through care packs.
Oh my god, do you see that?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
This is not fair.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What the fuck am I looking at?
You should stick by your teammates by the way.
Oh shit.
Bro!
Dude, they're literally just sitting on top of those rocks.
That's not fair.
Bro, I would be on that team.
They're going to have console.
Bro!
I would be on that team.
They have a console over there too.
I believe in this zone.
They made a new POI.
They're going to have Watson gens and stuff.
Oh my god.
You said back side, south side of C note?
All C notes open.
Wait, it might be the one in the far back.
It's like far left.
Yeah.
Bro!
Why can't I be on that team?
Brooo!
Bro!
Look at this!
I could ask a TPS to one of the houses.
Can we fight left building, the far left building, break all this up.
We have to, we have to.
We're here with the Navy, we're here walking them.
This is us behind you.
I can ulti the top of the wall.
Yeah, you should do that.
We have a secure.
Give me a smoke to run into, give me a smoke to run into.
This is actually crazy.
Ready to take the Ashe TP boys.
Oh I'm lagging in the server now.
Wait careful guys you might be shooting us.
One HP inside.
Oh no.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm following the crowd.
Careful not to kill each other.
I can't tell.
I can't.
There's so many.
Do not bang ult.
I'm gonna kill each other.
I'm on roof.
I'm on top.
Oh my god.
We're going in.
I can't.
We need to get inside the building if we can.
Okay.
Okay I'm inside.
I'm safe.
What is this?
What is going on?
I'm dead.
I'm coming.
I'm knocked.
I'm dead.
I'm gonna try to res you Mario.
I can't cross.
They're all trying to fucking push up.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
I don't know who's my teammate.
They're in building as well.
Right there Jens.
I can't see.
Wait someone's finishing.
I have a respawn beacon.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Is that the enemy?
I can't tell.
I actually can't tell.
Oh fuck okay.
There's too many people.
I'm inside the building right now.
Let me know.
I need a respawn.
Oh shit.
I stormed the beat.
This feels like war.
It's okay.
Good try.
We're still inside the building.
I got you.
Oh my god this is war.
Are you good?
I'm good.
Yes the building is still in.
I'm going.
I might kill you.
We need to get inside.
I think we need to get inside.
Yeah we do.
We need to get inside.
Some of them have blue armors in the building on the left.
Can we drill this building?
Yes I do.
In which building are we drilling?
They're playing the opposite side from us.
No one's inside middle right now as far as I can tell.
I'm coming through with a drill.
See if you can shove the building.
I'm going to respawn you ghost.
Empire close.
I knew the one.
I was going to destroy this one.
Oh my god.
Every time I try to get there I just throw on the drone.
Throw on the drone.
I'm about to suck your gas.
This is war.
I just spawned in.
On our roof.
You guys need to smoke the zip.
Someone smoked the crosswalk and that's our teammate.
There's so many things going on.
If you're going to do it you have to try right now.
No.
The fucking gas.
I couldn't tell which one.
I already used it.
Guys.
Naughty.
You're so fucked Naughty.
Use my...
You got this.
There's so many armor swaps.
No way.
I have no more shields.
Anyone here on this side of the fucking...
I don't know man.
Naughty.
Come on Naughty.
I know you're confused.
But I'm literally your teammate Naughty.
Naughty I'm literally your teammate.
Naughty.
I'm literally your teammate Naughty.
I know you're confused because there's so many people.
But I'm literally your teammate.
No.
I'm sorry Naughty.
I'm back here inside of C9 with you guys.
You guys got any meds?
I'm pretty low.
Of course the moment he res is...
I'm coming.
Shields.
Bro.
This is like the most unfair game.
This is actually the most unfair game ever.
To me.
Oh my god.
He hesitated.
I was so free to rest for the longest time.
This is actually.
I can't believe.
We actually have to run the beach.
I can't believe we actually had to do that.
We had to storm that beach.
That's actually crazy that that happened.
That.
That was actually.
fucking crazy.
But like.
It was the most unfair to us.
Cause we had to run to the beach.
We had to run to the beach.
The team had to run to the beach.
We reach against defence!
What the fuck!
War... War never changes.
Bro, there's no way our team's still alive.
There's no fucking way.
I don't think, I don't think.
There's no way the assault characters are alive.
There's no fucking way.
I think we're all dead.
We're all dead.
I legitimately think we're all dead.
War... it never changes.
It really does.
War is not fair, Doki.
Bro, look at how many of the defenders are still alive.
Like, they only lost five people.
Oh my god.
That's only five people died.
That's actually crazy.
This is 100% defense sided.
I lost the 50-50 chat.
I lost the lottery to be on team defense.
This is what Normandy feels like.
Oh my god.
They got the fucking...
They got the map... they got the zone.
They also got like...
They got the zone as defenders.
I think that's the worst part.
If they were playing the same...
I think if they were playing the same...
If they were on assault characters, I think it would be more fair.
But the fact that like...
They got the controller class and zone.
That was... that was fucked up, man.
That was so fucked up.
They actually won the gacha.
Yeah.
They got the best possible zone for this fight.
Holy shit.
That's so funny.
That's actually so funny.
I can't believe we had to run at the beach.
I can't believe that.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we had to run at the beach.
It's so poetic.
It actually is.
The thing is, I was so confused because I was worried I was going to shoot my old teammates.
That was the worst part.
I was just like...
Who's my teammate?
It doesn't matter when you're in the game.
But when you're in a fight, there's so many people around me, I couldn't tell.
And then we couldn't use Bangalore ult because we can ult ourselves.
So it was like...
We couldn't use Bangalore ult because we didn't want to kill ourselves with Bangalore ult.
I can't...
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
They're fighting each other.
We're fisting again.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's back to fisting.
Oh my god.
I like how we had like no man's land.
We established no man's land.
We're like, oh you can't cross no man's land.
But it didn't matter because the zone was like their zone.
So we had to cross.
We had...
Oh my god, we were all here.
We were all here for this.
The Apex Civil War.
We were all here for the Apex Civil War chat.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh true!
They're gens.
You're right because they established the gens.
War never changes.
We didn't get the zone or the class we wanted.
Yeah, we had the middle zone.
It would have been more balanced.
That was crazy though.
The fucking wall that they made.
That shit was insane.
Shit.
Like looking at that wall live was actually insane.
I can't believe that that was real.
I can't believe that was that.
I saw that.
And then the... and then the final zone was at the beach.
That was actually the craziest part.
That the final zone was at the fucking beach.
Yeah.
Take notes guys.
Take notes.
Alright.
How much was that?
That was uh...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
They get double the fucking price for that.
Okay.
Let me...
I need to know how much I got for that.
I must get like a hundred or some shit.
Alright.
Four five zero zero divide by thirty.
A hundred fifty!
I got a hundred fifty for that.
Nice.
That's fine.
A hundred fifty is nice.
Yeah, we got like major fucked up.
We actually got major fucked up there.
There's me.
I'm with Dwells and Sweet X Sage.
Dwells?
Who's Dwells?
Oh shit!
He's the Consul Pred!
He's Consul Pred!
That's even better!
Alright.
Let's see.
Um... and then I don't know who the other or my other one is.
This is like...
Let me check up.
X Sweet Sage.
Is this the right one?
No.
I typed it wrong.
I was like, that's not the right one.
Okay.
Our pro player is a Consul Pred.
It's three strikes.
Okay, but does he... does he...
Does he have like the uh...
the brains?
Okay.
Code is...
up.
Alright.
Code.
We got the code.
Alright.
We are team...
What team are we?
Uh...
We are team...
I already forgot our team.
15!
We're 15.
Okay.
Oh yeah, Sharko!
Make sure you drink lots of water!
Make sure!
Don't... don't be...
Don't drink... balance it out with water and stay safe, man.
Stay safe.
Okay, let me... Am I team 15 again?
Alright.
Team 15.
Holy fuck.
That was like...
Bruh.
What the fuck was that game?
Wait...
Oh my god.
I'm still trying to...
I'm still fucking processing what we just played.
Like it was... it was actually we... saving Private Ryan right there, but what have we failed?
Like...
Oh my god.
That's actually insane.
Alright.
Uh...
I went through some PTSD shit right there.
Alright, we're joining...
We're supposed to join team 15!
Team 15.
That's so...
Hi.
Hello!
Go Evan, bro.
Hit him for like 20 damage.
Okay, which... were you guys on the control... were you guys on the winning team or the losing team?
Cause I felt like...
Oh, losing team.
Okay, were we all...
were we all losing?
Okay, what the fuck was that?
What the... they got the beach.
We recreated... we recreated World War 2.
But like...
In my history of playing Apex Legends the last four years, have I ever seen that zone.
We... we literally had to storm the beach, but like...
we lost.
Like... that's not what history taught me.
What the fuck happened?
History didn't teach me this.
Like...
That was so rough.
My frames were dead.
My frames were dying.
I was on like 90 frames.
You were on 90 frames?
Aren't you on roller?
You don't need the frames.
Yes, I do.
You're on roller.
Does it matter?
I can't even shoot my gun.
It was terrible.
That was terrible.
Of course they get the zone and they were on control...
they were on the controller characters.
Like...
what the fuck?
Yeah, no.
That zone was crazy.
I've never seen it end on that little rock like that.
That was actually fucking insane.
Apparently only five people died on the other team.
That's fucked up.
Oh, it was five?
Yeah.
That was just one.
They said...
They said five people died on their side while our entire team got wiped out.
We didn't even get a single we only got five.
I think I got to shoot my gun twice.
I was just smoking.
I was scared.
I was scared I was gonna shoot my own teammates.
I was so fucking Everybody was just like in my face.
If that zone pulled the middle it would have been so much different.
I feel like... Yeah, that would have been a lot more...
Wasn't there a map where you could turn off zones?
Why didn't we do that?
Yeah, you can.
There is a way to make it where you can turn off zones and just like everybody meets up in one spot and just battles it out.
I feel like it's all in one spot.
Yeah!
Why didn't... Why didn't we just do that instead of letting...
Instead of letting everybody in one spot?
I didn't even have all of this.
Alright, who are we playing?
Who are we playing?
We need a Newcastle.
I think.
I feel like Newcastle is very helpful here.
Oh yeah.
Or Mirage at least.
Oh, that means three strikes so it's Newcastle uh... maybe Conduit?
Conduit Horizon.
Newcastle Conduit Horizon.
Last time... Last time I played the last one I just died off rip because literally like we didn't have any kind of character that we could fight with.
Yeah.
Wait, what did you play last time?
We were playing Conduit, Newcastle, and Caustic.
It was that.
Okay, so we just don't have Caustic then.
We should have like someone...
Yeah.
I'm gonna play Horizon.
Oh.
I can do Conduit or Newcastle.
Which one do you prefer, Sage?
Um...
I don't think she wants either or.
No, I like... Oh, are you saying like of those two which one would I prefer?
Which one I would want to be.
Yeah, which one do you want to play?
Like which one are you more comfortable in?
I'm a Conduit main.
Oh yeah, I'll just play Newcastle.
Okay.
And this time I'll use my shield.
I was on a team with Timmy for the the no strikes, three strikes or something and then he kept yelling shield but I thought he meant Conduit shield so I never...
No!
He was like, shield, shield, shield!
And I looked at my Conduit and I was like where the fuck is the shield?
And then, but he meant me.
He was talking to me and I was like, oh!
And then we died so I didn't understand.
I was like where was the Newcastle shield?
I was like, oh you were talking to me!
Cause he's... after shield he said Q.
So I looked at my Conduit and I was like give me the Q.
No, you're so real.
I was like, yeah, where is it?
Oh my gosh.
So if you... so if you want me to use my Newcastle shield, please say Newcastle before you die.
Oh, I didn't know we were on Olympics.
You need to be specific.
I feel a little bit better.
Alright.
Make sure you're not on Fuse.
I'll be on Newcastle.
Watts and mains are like eating this tourney.
For real.
I mean the next round is...
The next round is...
Punching again.
I hope somebody plays Crypto this time.
I think that's what's gonna happen.
Bucks a good choice too.
Wait, where are we dropping?
Did we even call a zone?
We didn't even call.
But I think we can go...
I don't even know what's gonna be free.
Maybe Oracle?
I have no idea.
I didn't even check.
I don't know.
I'm on 130 ping.
Are y'all on high ping?
Nope.
Oh wait, yes.
160.
What the fuck?
This is not even East Coast anymore.
We're on Europe.
No, we're on Europe.
I get 100 ping on Tokyo.
This is Europe.
Wait, what the hell?
Do you wanna go like way back here?
Yeah, just go wherever.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna be really mad then.
I'm on 150 ping on Europe.
I think there's one person coming here.
I'm pretty sure there is a team.
We're getting conned.
Do you wanna go here or do you wanna go here?
And then we can go to Icarus.
There's a team in Icarus though.
Oh, okay.
Just go to the compound.
Just go to the compound that you ping.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, no balls?
You don't wanna con them?
We have three strikes.
Yeah, my flying was kinda...
Yeah, I apologize.
I was looking around too much.
Trying to figure out where the hell I was going.
My ping is going up.
Oh, okay, match ended.
Thank fucking god.
Okay, I was gonna say.
How is my ping going higher?
I was gonna...
Fucking Brazil servers or something.
We're in...
We're in fucking Sao Paulo?
We're in Sao Paulo?
Oh my god, back in rank we go.
Someone was on lifeline.
It's like nobody on Horizon this time.
I'm seeing a lot of Newcastle Conduit, Caustic actually.
Oh!
It reset to London.
Oh my god.
I knew it was EU.
I was like, this is EU ping.
There's no fucking way.
Everybody's on Conduit, Caustic and Watson.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
Yeah, I mean that worked out.
We're stealing strats from other people.
Wait, someone has it on Mirage?
Who's that genius?
Who the fuck is cooking right now?
It's that, uh, Tempur guy.
Oh no.
I don't think Giggle got it, like, into play.
I think they started without.
It's okay.
Okay.
Round two.
Now we're definitely not in London.
Okay, how's it going?
How good are your zone reads?
Who?
Well, of course you, the fucking pro player that's rank one.
I'm not a pro player.
Aspiring pro player.
I just got here.
I just got to PC like two months ago.
I'm being called a pro player.
Again?
I'm not bad at reading zones.
I'm not horrible at it.
Okay, but like, if you had, what is your position in your team?
The roller player?
Yeah, yeah.
I have feelings.
The one on controller.
I play Bloodhound.
Alright.
Are y'all both on M&A?
Yes.
Absolutely.
Of course.
I'm just a content creator.
I haven't shot my gun.
Every single game, I've barely gotten to shoot my gun.
I feel like I'm dead.
What the fuck?
Bro, you're giving me so much hope right now for our team.
I am.
Listen, I'm completely and totally ready.
You're supposed to hype us up.
What the fuck happened?
I am.
You barely shot your gun.
I'm ready to drop a 6k.
You barely shot your gun, but this is the game that's gonna change.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
I'm warmed up.
You are so warmed up with the zero kills, man.
You're so...
Bro, I had a kill.
I had a kill before you had a kill.
And I'm the content creator.
Bro, what's going on?
You got rank 1.
What happened?
Did you fall off?
No, I'm not falling off.
Did you?
Don't worry.
This is the game that's gonna change, right?
This is it.
I got zero damage in the duels game, if that makes you feel anybody.
We got placed 8th, though.
Yeah, I got last.
I got last place in the duels, because Dropped was AFK getting chicken and rice.
So we had zero plans.
No way!
He went and got chicken and rice, and I asked him if it was worth it, and he said, yeah.
Oh no!
As long as it was worth it, I guess.
We still got $100 out of chicken and rice.
So...
Okay, period.
I love that.
Yeah, last place still gets $100.
That's all that matters.
I believe this is it.
You're gonna frag out here.
You've like...
You've like stored all your fragging energy for this one game.
Because after this game, you're just gonna be punching people.
This is your last chance to shoot your gun.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, this is his actual last chance to shoot the gun.
Got this.
Easy peasy.
Also, how's the switch from console to PC?
I think he like AFK'd a cry.
No!
No, don't cry.
Maybe he went to go get some...
some snack.
Yeah, he's just on a snack break.
He's just on a snack break, guys.
Chicken and rice.
It's okay.
He's not gonna...
He's off to get his own chicken and rice chat.
He's off to get his own chicken and rice.
We got this.
Easy peasy.
I believe in our team.
We can't get worse.
Alright.
Maybe we picked the right character.
He did.
Alright.
Wait, are you actually still here?
Who else?
No, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he's actually on AFK.
Like actually gone?
I think he's AFK.
Okay, if he's in the bathroom that long...
I don't think he's okay.
Yeah, wash your hands.
I don't think he's okay if he's in the bathroom that fucking long.
Okay,
we're in the right area now.
Let's hope that he's not Jump Master.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Cause I'm pretty sure he's still AFK.
I'm scared.
Where are we supposed to land?
I don't know now.
Now I don't know.
It's AFK!
We couldn't check.
Oh, you have terrible luck.
Just like...
How does two teammates go AFK?
Oh my god.
I really don't know where to go.
I think we probably should just land right here.
We're going back.
We're repeating this.
I mean, we have a teammate that's AFK.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Yeah.
Like I don't wanna like...
I don't wanna contest anywhere.
Where no people are gonna be at.
I don't think it's a coincidence anymore.
Two teammates that are AFK.
Now we'll split off.
Are you back?
Yeah, I'm back.
Oh shit, what happened to you?
Where did you go?
Nowhere.
We were talking to you!
You didn't talk to us!
Talking to chat.
Oh my god!
You didn't even fucking answer back to us.
We had important questions about this game!
We were meta crafting!
We were theory crafting!
Oh, but I did ask you how you feel about switching from console to PC.
It's good.
It feels better.
More crisp.
More responsive.
That's good.
We got a lot of cool people.
They got a little car right there.
I'm gonna grab this.
I wanna go try to fight the team at orbital, Loki.
Y'all got guns?
Yeah, I do.
I'm down to fight.
I'm okay to fight.
Alright, let's walk up and hope we're okay.
Did I see them?
On me.
Literally on my roof.
I'm here now.
Oh my gosh.
Newcastle's weak.
Wait, there's a team on...
There's a third on the roof.
I'm gonna fucking ape this guy.
I'm gonna ape this guy right here.
Yeah, I'm inside the building.
I don't see anybody.
I'm going over to our...
He's by himself.
I don't know if I can kill him.
I don't have Q.
Nice.
Oh my god, you did it!
You got the kill!
Congratulations!
I'm so proud of you!
This is the game that's gonna turn around.
I knew it.
I got the shield.
Upgrade.
Who's this one?
I'm gonna Q in two.
I'm just gonna wait for it.
They're both up here.
Yeah.
Uh, they jumped down.
We gotta wipe this so we can get our fucking... get their loot.
It's just two.
It's a few.
Are they in the building?
Yeah, they're inside here.
Y'all drop through that door.
I'm going in.
I'm going in now.
That's my nade.
He's almost cracked again.
Hit 50 on blue.
That's mine.
I'm going in.
He's on your side.
Knock, knock, knock, knock, knock.
Dead.
Full dead.
Nice.
Good job.
Hey!
Easy.
Nothing to worry about.
Uh...
We need to make sure they don't drop back on us.
They might land on us.
Yeah, I'm trying to heal up.
Get their loot back.
I do kinda want a better light gun.
So if you see like a R9 or a 301.
Me too.
I have an RE.
Same.
Which isn't the best.
I dropped a purple energy mag.
Level 3.
Uh...
It's a Havoc here if anyone wants that.
Um... no thank you.
Hmm...
Where do you think zones gonna end?
I can't read zones at all.
It's gonna pull back to phase driver, Banzai.
It's probably gonna hard pull back to fucking phase driver back here.
So we should head over now just to grab a spot.
Yeah possibly.
See if we can, yeah.
I grabbed an ulti-excel for us.
Yeah ping me any...
Sage and I need light guns.
Better light guns so we can find any.
There's an R9 in one of those boxes.
There is?
I'll go.
Is it from the horizon you killed?
Yeah it's the horizon box.
It's like right there I'm pretty sure.
Oh he crawled all the way there?
Unless it like is gone now.
Yeah it's gone.
God it's gone.
Yeah no worries.
We'll find something.
They're fighting in front of us at this choke.
They're poking I don't know if they're fighting.
I feel like we should just get like a spot cause like kills don't really matter to us.
Yeah I'm just getting people out faster.
In the end they're just gonna...
It's just gonna like uh...
What was it?
Lock up the...
The respawn anyway by then?
By then?
Is someone...
No okay.
I thought it was a car.
It's even Icarus.
Oh that landed in there.
Uh...
Uh take this blue knock.
Oh wait not me.
Haha just kidding.
Right here.
I'm ready.
Right in front of us right there.
Just land on the building right here.
Okay.
Right here we can shoot this kid in the back.
I'm shooting.
Cracked one!
I cracked one!
I'm gonna ult.
I'm getting on the building.
Oh my god what happened to my ult?
I'm batting.
Yeah he already used it.
There's somebody over here.
Over here.
The last guy is over here.
The last guy is on me.
Right here.
I'll try to kill him if y'all can.
He's kinda... I don't know.
He ran ran.
I had the jitterbug.
I can't get him.
Yeah you can come back.
You can come back.
I think he's just gonna wait for them to crawl back to them.
Yeah but there's this other team like right here.
I don't wanna like separate too much.
I think... I feel like I should get knocked.
and you guys should res me.
No no no no.
I don't want them to like int.
Yeah but okay.
I'll just full heal then.
Where are the bodies that we killed?
Cause they're just gonna crawl to him.
They're just crawling towards him.
Okay.
Where is, um...
We're still playing left side of Icarus over here.
Back here if we can.
How many bats do y'all have?
I have four.
I have two.
I think there might be a team still in here so be careful.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh just right here where they were before.
Yeah can you call me?
I'm gonna get right behind here.
I don't know if I can get to you.
I'm gonna get to Wells actually maybe.
Yeah he's looking at me right now.
Oh no.
Can you ult us?
Just ult us.
No I don't have ult.
I don't have ult.
I used it already.
That's like... yeah.
I didn't have ult.
He's pushing.
Mirage pushing.
He's behind this box.
I think?
Because I see... yeah.
I'm calling back.
Probably bat.
I don't have Q yet.
I'm batting.
I'm just throwing these.
I have four.
I see you.
Look at Gromp.
Rotate through.
Rotate through right now.
Pushing.
Yeah that's the... that's the team that we knocked earlier in the past.
I'm gonna grab something.
Team at this building.
There's a classic team in here.
I have Q.
I... I have ult here.
They're just sitting in the building.
I have like no frames right now.
Wow out.
88.
Noo Castle one.
Back one.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going one.
Pull dead, pull dead, pull dead.
I'll raise ours.
I'm gonna raise.
I'm grabbing this R9.
Okay, go.
I want the shiiiits.
I have a- the fucking- that jitterbug, my body is like shaking.
Oh, that's not good.
Um, I had it 2 for a moment.
I don't know what it is.
My frames are really bad right now too.
Yeah, my frames are really bad too.
I have like 80 frames.
I was about to say flames.
I'm okay.
Don't worry, I'll be here.
You're gonna have to kill everybody.
Don't worry, I can clutch this for us.
You got it.
I'm leaving you.
I need like, uh...
Let's see.
Oh, I see you have a purple knockdown.
I need that.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I'm like- oh, it's like only in that spot I'm like jittering really bad.
Okay, I dropped the blue for us.
Am I really close?
I wonder if I can reset my game.
I don't know.
That is risky.
I mean, I like- I'm fucking shaking all over the place.
It might be- it might just be because we're on the edge of the map.
Like the closer I get like- No, it's been the whole game.
It's been the whole game.
For you?
Okay.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
Just do it now.
Might as well.
Nah, it's fine.
It's fine.
Are you sure?
Like, if you can do it now then- I just don't wanna like- just not getting back into the game.
Okay, that's fair.
We gotta rotate.
Hey.
Sometimes you can join back, sometimes you can't.
We're just gonna play underneath here.
We just hold everybody out.
If there's not a team here- there needs a team here, actually.
The Watts and Newcastle team all left side, right there.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to fight them.
Try to like get them off of it.
I do have ult.
I also have ult, but- Newcastle one!
Newcastle one!
Ooh!
They are coming here.
Hold on.
I'm gonna ult here then.
Am I ult up front?
And we have to because of this shit.
Oh, they just ulted.
Oh no.
I might be dead to this.
Maybe.
I'm fine.
I'm fine for now.
Okay.
You're gonna have to- We're gonna shoot them in.
We're just getting hit.
Oh, the nade.
Yeah.
Right here.
This is bad.
I might die to- oh wait, I'm s- I'm dead.
Just gotta keep spam pressing.
Try to spam press.
Yeah, I'm going for it.
I'm going for it now.
I'm gonna die.
They're pushing right here.
Yeah.
A Cossack's one-shot.
I'm just gonna try to spam press you.
I can't freaking see anything.
Oh, I can.
I got knocked here.
I think with this we just have to...
Nice.
Play Song Tian.
Good job.
Nice.
I think you might be able to get a res.
Yeah.
Oh no.
Good shit.
Nice.
No shot.
Got you.
Oh, I got knocked a bit.
Oh, wrong person.
Sorry.
No, the team to the right got us.
No way.
They're just focusing us.
They're not shooting that team at all.
Yeah.
It's okay.
We had two restraints.
We just gotta- we can rotate to a better position.
Yeah.
Trying to figure out what a better position is.
Do you want to try up here or no?
Or like- like- I don't have a- Land on this bridge.
Land on this bridge.
Land on this bridge right here.
Okay.
There's people under it.
I'm gonna look inside.
There's a full team inside.
Fuck.
I have a Q behind us.
I'm gonna Q behind us.
Nice.
Should we come down?
I'm gonna come down to you.
I knocked- I'm shooting on this team inside so hard.
Okay, okay, okay.
I knocked one and shot on two.
There's another team.
Another team is looking at us right now.
Okay, okay.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
They rez'd it.
Yeah, I mean- we might be able to rotate backside this way.
I can.
I'm getting shot- I'm getting shot from the other team.
I don't have Q, sorry.
Yeah, it's fine.
You can just Q me back up.
I mean, like, can- Yeah.
Team right here.
Jump underneath!
There's nobody underneath!
Jump underneath, Sage.
I'm dead.
I fell through a hole.
Ooh.
Can you get underneath?
Yeah, I'm getting underneath.
Yeah, I'm under- I'm under.
Spawn near each other.
There's a person right here!
In the... like, they're right here!
Underneath!
I think you can get the res off.
He's just chilling, it's a fucking fuse.
Nice.
Oh, he had the looking machine.
I'm trying to shield it.
I don't know where they are.
Oh, they dropped down.
They're right here.
I mean, there's nothing I can do.
Yeah, they're hard pushing now.
Nice try.
It's hard.
It's like...
Having to drop when everyone's already in fucking buildings is rough.
Like, this is what makes it so annoying.
Where do we do that?
I'm trying to look, I'm trying to look, I'm trying to look.
Is anybody on height?
There's a team on height.
Do you want to try, like, on the wall right there?
Just land here, land here on me, land here on me.
Just like, try to AFK here in this corner.
Try to AFK in this corner.
Try to AFK in a corner.
Yeah, I'm trying.
They're... they're inting.
No, they can't jump down.
They'll fucking get fried.
Just AFK in a corner.
Literally, just AFK in this corner right here.
I... I'm in a different corner, but...
Hey, climb up when you can.
Just AFK here.
There's a team on the right.
Just literally don't make any noise.
Don't show any to sign up live here.
Just living here.
This is our home.
All these fucking Skynaids.
They don't have a Watson above us, I'm pretty sure.
Um, I think they do.
I hear a bunch of...
Do they?
Yeah, I hear a bunch of, like, shit.
There was a Vengeance up there earlier so I thought maybe...
How long until our ults, by the way?
Uh, fifty?
Um... I'm at fifty.
Yeah, I'm at fifty-two.
Oh, Sage, nice.
Look underneath, look underneath right here, look underneath right here.
Tommy, I'm just dead.
Oh my God, I got you, I got you.
You got a new castle wall.
You got a new castle wall if you have it.
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
Oh, dude.
There's... yeah, there's just people down here I feel.
Oh my god, what?
It's just so much.
There's literally just like two, three teams sitting right there.
There's so many people!
They all shot us!
They all wanted us dead!
Yeah, that was rough.
Holy shit!
Oh, we were fucked.
There was no way we were gonna get to zone.
There was no way.
Yeah, that's rough.
We were not even close to zone.
Alright, nice try.
GG's!
See you guys in the next one!
GG's, GG's.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, that zone pull was actually crazy.
We were not even like gonna...
We were not even gonna fucking...
We were so far!
This is where the zone landed onto!
We were here!
How will we travel?
How are we gonna travel all the way?
GG's!
Yeah, that was... that was insane.
That was actually...
We peaked early, chat.
We actually peaked early.
We were like everybody aiming at...
Yes!
Everybody shot at us!
Holy fuck!
There was no way to live!
That poor man!
That poor man got...
Oh my god, that poor man got destroyed.
I didn't forget to Q this time.
Yeah!
I remembered to Q this time.
Yeah, I shot my gun!
We all shot our gun!
Thank god.
There was actually like...
No way to play.
Everyone really...
What the fuck was that sound?
What the fuck was that gun sound?
No more...
Now no more gun.
Now it's back to fisting.
Chat, we're back.
I was getting too much money.
It was getting too good for too long.
I was getting way too much money.
Yeah, that was a very weird energy gun sound.
My guy.
True.
Next one is LG, by the way, chat.
The next one is LG.
Oh, gee.
Okay, I hope... is this fucked up to say?
Wait,
I think they... oh my god!
Oh my god, I hope Timmy doesn't place higher so...
so like, I would be the best team they had.
No, that's... I'm joking.
I'm joking.
No, he's gonna place higher.
He's gonna win.
I'm fucking... I bet you he's gonna win.
He literally has deeds.
Like, on his team.
Like, they're set.
They're actually set.
And he has an EVA-8?!
Bro, where was I luck there?
To be fair, I didn't fucking... I didn't fucking queue.
That's my luck.
That's his luck.
Bro, he literally has deeds!
That's fucking crazy!
He literally has deeds on his team!
That's insane.
He got fifth?!
Yes!
He was no... their team was no better!
Better than my team... our team!
They got fifth?!
We're the same!
You think about it.
We're the same.
Our team is the same.
It didn't matter.
Our team won.
We both... when I was on Timmy's team, we also placed fifth.
Timmy... when Timmy is not on my team, he also placed fifth.
So, it didn't matter.
It actually did not matter.
It's the same.
My sportsmanship is off the roof.
I hope Joel didn't take my banter as too harsh.
I hope he actually didn't get angry!
I just was trying to lighten the mood...
I hope he realized that this was some friendly banter.
Hopefully.
I hope I didn't make him cry...
Hold on!
It's VTubers now!
Join the club!
Join the fucking club!
We're playing Apex here.
Normies...
Normies don't know what to do.
Okay, let's see.
What's our last team?
Alright, our last team is...
Oh, we got Naughty again.
And we got Sage.
What is this random...
This is not random!
I get the same teammates all the time!
I swear!
I literally got Sage and Naughty before!
This is not random!
This is not...
Where is the variation here?
I literally played with Naughty and I just played with Sage...
This is the last game!
How is this random?
Spotify Shuffle be like...
Has rigged this for me?
In what way?
He rigged it the opposite direction!
If it was rigged, I would be on the winning team!
If this was rigged, I would have been on control!
I would have been on fucking control!
And...
On the other side!
I would not have been an assault character!
Alright, let's see...
We new code, new code...
Where is the new code?
New code, here we go...
Alright, new code time...
New code!
What did I play last time?
Watson, right?
Yeah, I was on Watson.
Watson!
Okay...
I didn't leak the code like last... I didn't leak the code like Hal did.
Uhhhh...
I was hoping they were there first so I can just join off of them, but they weren't, so I need to fucking look up the leaderboard shit again.
Let's see...
Team 14!
Team 14...
Alright...
Let's see, let me get my boogie up just in case...
Can't believe it...
What happens to meeting new people?
But not too many new...
Not too many new people though!
I like to meet new people gradually.
Like two at a time.
Meeting new people.
I can't believe... I can't believe I got the same teammates as...
What are the odds?
I feel like almost every game I met like the...
Like one new... one of the person...
One person would be the person I played with last game.
Tempo gave me a head start with Jen and Timmy and said you're on your own.
And then after that I was like now it's real random.
Basically...
One or two people at a time.
Alright... but it was cool.
It was great that we got to play with Timmy and Jen though.
And like 30 seconds...
One minute was dropped.
The one minute one minute was dropped was like the peak there for me.
That was with the chicken and rice.
That shit was peak right there.
Chicken and rice.
There we go.
Uh...
Hello.
Hello again, Sage.
Hello again, Naughty.
Hello, hello.
I can't believe this is... I've been playing with the same people all day.
Bro, it's not random!
It's not random.
They're just putting us back to back with people.
I refuse to believe this is random.
Yeah, I think it's like just...
I don't even know.
Just like either crazy luck or... Bro!
But then how did some teams get like all the pros?
How does that happen?
What the fuck?
At least like when you're random, you'll be like, wait, this doesn't look fair.
Let me just move them a little bit.
Like, what the fuck?
Timmy and Deeds on the same team?
On a game mode where you actually shoot the gun?
I got Jen on my first game, but he doesn't... we don't shoot our guns because we're fisting people.
Like...
We got another no gun here.
This one.
These are like crazy unguards.
So, pros...
Okay, are you the guy that knows zones?
Are you the zone guy for your team?
I know the zones, you know, somewhat.
The zones we've been playing today have been crazy.
Oh yeah, no, they were terrible.
Yeah, they've been so bad.
They're like hard to guess too, but...
We should get a good guess here.
Wait, did you call your POI yet?
Yeah, yeah.
Down Beast.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Yep, yep.
We got down...
I'm on Watts... oh, Watts in.
Yep, you got Watts in.
And then I'll play Valk, and then if you wanna play Lifeline, Sage?
Yeah.
Or would you rather...
I can play Lifeline.
Okay.
Do you not think that's a good...
Oh no, I can play Lifeline.
Yeah, it's fine.
Also, is there a slight echo?
Yeah, yeah, no, it's not.
I'm not using.
There's an echo.
Here, let me...
Sorry about that.
No, it's okay.
I was like, maybe I'm just really listening to myself.
I don't know.
Okay.
That's my mic.
Maybe somebody this time is gonna play Crypto.
Oh yeah, I'm late.
After the lessons we've learned on the first game.
Maybe someone will actually play Crypto this time.
I believe.
Wait, what's the Lifeline for?
Uh, for the self-revive?
I took my headphones out, so if you're talking, I can't hear you.
Oh, wait, but would it matter though for self-revive?
Because we're all just gonna fucking be in the mosh pit in the end.
Well, I mean, yeah, it'll definitely get you some extra placements though.
You know, just like...
Because you still have to get Thirsted as Lifeline if you get knocked.
But at the same time, you might be right regarding that because there's so many fences.
But if there's a Crypto, Lifeline's so good.
Like if Crypto blows everything up.
Takes all the fences out.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I was just thinking like, uh...
I was just thinking like, oh man.
Are we...
Will she even survive long enough to...
Yeah, it's kinda... Honestly, maybe like a Wraith instead of Lifeline?
I don't know.
Or like Caustic.
Caustic was really good for my first game.
For your no punch?
Yeah, yeah, no punch.
Because we just had the gas cannons to like, make them knock...
Like, you know, take some extra damage.
Yeah, I mean, duh.
With like gens and stuff, it's hard to do that.
That's true.
At the end zone.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
But like...
At the same time, like, it also kills and doesn't really matter, you know?
But like, then again, it is only flesh damage that matters.
It's just like, spacing.
Spacing-wise.
Yeah, I mean, Wasson's like insane to like, spam fences around.
Cause like, people can't shoot him, and people can't shoot your gen, you know?
You can literally play wherever.
Yeah.
You can play like, in the wide open.
Like, everyone looking at you.
Alright, so we're gonna do Lifeline or Wraith then?
For Sage.
Um...
Mmm... That's a good question.
You made a good point.
Cause I think Valk will be really good.
Yeah, Valk for ending.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
Uh...
I think Wattson and Valk 100%.
And then...
Mmm...
What do you think, Sage?
Sage die?
You think like Wraith, Portal, Valk or...
Lifeline?
Sage?
Okay, Sage is AFK at day...
I think she's AFK!
Yeah.
We'll wait for Sage to get back and...
We have plenty of time.
Yeah.
We have plenty of time to theorycraft.
How well have your games been?
So far?
Decent.
Middle of the pack.
How about you?
Middle of the pack?
I think I got like two top 5's in the beginning and then I peaked and then...
I peaked very early on.
And then...
Ever since then, it's not been great.
Ever since then, Tempo has definitely rigged it against me.
Yeah.
Putting us in...
in the assault category.
Oh, that... yeah, that was horrible.
I think that was the turn...
My turning point was when I dropped AFK for Duos.
And...
And then...
I got ratted out instantly.
No way.
How did he go AFK?
He was getting his chicken and rice.
He was getting his dinner.
And then...
And then I... I got...
I walked up, did not see a full team in front of me and died!
Oh my gosh.
That stinks.
Oh!
Is everybody waiting for me?
No, that's not it.
Where am I?
No, I'm not.
I was on the game.
Team 14.
No, what the fuck?
I was already in Team 14!
What?
Did they say something to you?
My chat was like, they're waiting for you.
And I was like, what?
I didn't even realize.
I didn't even see that.
I wasn't even in Team 5!
Yeah, Team 5.
I'm not even the last person!
There's a Team 5!
Did we claim down Beast already?
Yeah.
Yep, we got it.
I believe unconfessed.
Alright, nice.
Oh,
they forced moved me.
Alright, but I still wasn't the last person.
I wasn't holding it up.
They were people.
The Zyneful and Gengar...
Okay, it's alright.
It's fisting around.
So it doesn't matter.
I'm lowkey.
I think they're actually moving.
I'm gonna look around for Crypto.
Actually, they won't be on it yet.
Hello.
Did you say, um, so yes to Lifeline?
Was there anything else you talked about?
Oh yeah, if you wanna do Lifeline or Wraith, which would you prefer?
Probably Wraith.
Okay, I'm not a giant.
But if you want to be...
Yeah, she could save her Q for the final zone.
Yeah, that could be a whole other thing too.
Yeah.
It's sort of like up in the air with like if Lifeline self-revive or Wraith's portal will stall longer than the other, you know?
I feel like the Wraith...
Cause like if she gets knocked out outside a zone when it's tiny, then like that'd be fucked for her.
Yeah.
I just... like if there's a Crypto that would be good for us.
But...
Cause that would like help everyone sort of just...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Someone must go Crypto.
There must be somebody on the enemy team that's gonna go Crypto.
There's no way.
After what happened in the first game, I refuse to believe no one's gonna go Crypto.
Yeah.
Unless everyone's thinking the same thing we are and we're like Yeah, there's gonna be someone that's Crypto.
Totally.
There has to be.
But there's like so many of us here.
There's so many.
There's no way one person's not gonna pick Crypto.
We just need one guy.
We literally need one guy to Crypto out.
Oh, Spikes would be good actually.
Oh.
What about Catalyst with Cat Spikes?
Someone just mentioned that in my chat.
Catalyst with Cat Spikes?
Like Final Final as well.
Like Final Final?
Yeah, but does Watson all eat it?
Or no?
Yeah.
It does.
Wait, wait, wait.
Watson.
Okay, I almost couldn't find Watson.
Yeah.
You're already on Watson.
You're chillin'.
Oh, nice.
Thank god.
I feel like Watson all eats Catalyst stuff, right?
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
It doesn't matter.
We had a Fuse and it didn't matter because there were so many Watson ults.
There were so many.
Yeah, I should've thought about that too because we had a Fuse too.
We were like Fuse...
What were we?
Fuse, Watson...
Lifeline I think actually.
Yeah.
I think the Fuse ult doesn't get ate by Watson gen unless I'm trippin'.
I think that's why people are trying to Fuse.
We're not beasts by the way.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Ready, out.
I am so bad with... yeah.
You might want to take...
You might want to take off from me.
I'm really bad with landing.
Oh no, you're Chon.
You're Chon.
We shouldn't be contested.
Yeah.
There's no way.
They saw Nottie's game on there and they're like we wouldn't contest him.
Yeah, I'm not punchin' him.
Punch out.
Yeah, they're like, oh fuck it's Nottie.
Here, I'll land.
I'll land far.
Alright.
One of you guys can land like close.
I'll grab the other side of down beast.
Or I'll grab inside down beast.
Yep, that's perfect.
Okay.
So you can have the outside.
The crust.
Yay.
Where are people?
Right here.
Oh, they're right here, right here.
Oh, they have the car.
They just grabbed that car.
That's fine, we don't need it.
Yeah, we'll be Chon.
My range is short circuited.
We're gonna be looking around for caches and stuff.
Wait, actually, maybe we do need it.
I might get this car over here, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh wait, I think... Three right next to each other.
That's so pretty.
I like subconsciously picked up guns because we were shooting.
Yeah, I got like really excited when I saw the vault.
Yes.
We're getting this car, we're Chon.
You have a car?
Yeah, I got the mill car.
Okay, I got an evac.
If anyone wants this.
Oh my god, I just...
I just realized I threw away my shield cells.
Yeah, you can't even take guns.
Okay.
Alright, ulti cells are huge in this one, too.
I have no ulti cells.
I'm gonna carry all of them.
Also gotta make sure we have this car.
Oh wait, what do I need this for?
Make sure nobody steals it.
There's a lot of thermites and stuff here.
Isn't there evac if anyone wants it?
I already have an evac.
Let's definitely start going for caches.
Sooner than later.
There's an individual... Oh, they're stealing it!
No!
Caches?
I could probably punch them out.
They're by themselves.
I mean, caches are free.
If it's forever.
Yeah, get outta here.
Oh, nevermind.
It's too...
It's okay, just if you get punched out, we can pick you up.
I'm coming over!
Are they chasing me?
Oh, they are, yeah.
They're actually chasing you.
What the fuck?
Freaks!
What are these freaks doing?
Don't worry.
Oh my gosh, the nades.
There's so many nades.
We're here, we're here.
This guy's actually trying to 3v3 us.
Wait, they took our car!
Get out!
No!
No, they're not!
Get out!
They're broke.
Okay, I'm grabbing the car.
There's a thermite on it.
I don't know if it's theirs or mine.
Write this one, write this one.
I got the car, I got the car, I got the car!
He just ran over!
Punch him!
Punch him out!
Nice!
Nice.
That was a good Arcstar stack.
Let's go.
That was huge.
Nice.
We should guide it.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna guide it with my fences.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Watch that barrel.
Alright.
They want their buddies back.
That is free evo points right there.
They want their buddy back.
That's good.
I used all my nades that was on.
They gotta get through this fence.
Oh my gosh.
No, they really tried to steal the car.
That was so funny.
Are they still here?
Oh, this game is so intense.
They might be.
Wait, we should grab that phoenix kit first.
They took the cannon, right?
Yeah, they took the cannon.
They might come back.
We should grab some armor stuff though.
We can drive them.
We can do the ring too for extra.
Oh, sorry.
I'm in.
No, you're good.
I need some nades too, so I'm just trying to like, a little more.
And then we'll do like a ring console nades and stuff.
My fences are still there.
So like, I don't know.
Maybe they're crafting him back?
Maybe.
Oh, they're bringing him back.
Oh, wait, they brought him back?
Yeah, they did.
I'm ready now.
No way.
Where are they?
They're right here.
I'm out of punch design.
He's not laying on the cannon.
Oh, they ulted.
Back out, back out.
Backing out.
Get the car.
They took the car.
No, we got the car.
Yeah!
Oh, they went through your fences.
I'm going up to the car.
They took the car.
He actually has a car.
I can't believe it.
They actually, we got baited.
Alright, alright.
We're gonna let him go.
We'll let him go.
Yeah, we should.
Yeah, yeah.
We should grab.
No, I feel like we really should grab, do like, more arm or something.
Oh my god, my heart sank.
I thought that was a different team coming in.
Yeah, let's go get this cashier.
Ignore this.
It's a beautiful win.
It was in your honor, actually.
Yeah, I wanna grab some armor cash.
We'll take this back and then go get this cash up top.
I can't believe they actually did it.
The zone should probably go that way.
No, that was a good play.
I'm not gonna lie.
I didn't even think about bringing the card back close to them.
Not, yeah.
Oh my god.
If I had another arc, he's not getting in that though.
Yeah, I know.
Same.
I didn't have any other arc.
I had only nades and...
I only had nades and thermites.
The madman.
Dyn is tripping.
No, that was funny.
I'm gonna go the ring console.
Yep, yep.
Go for it right behind you.
We'll go this console and then that package is probably taken.
It's not taking it, what the heck.
Nice.
What's that?
Get the cash out of it, maybe?
Whoa!
What's that?
Oh, I forgot.
I put a ring in here.
People up here.
Let me know they're coming over.
I have a ring around me.
Okay.
Yeah, it's okay.
No, you're good.
Alright, I got it.
We'll hit this again as well in 20 seconds.
Questing.
I dropped a nade if you guys want one.
It's a Watson, I think, up there.
On the tippity top of the building.
That you just walked into.
We should go over here.
Yeah, I'm leaving it.
I'm leaving it.
Hit the beacon again for the zone.
She's coming down.
She's right here.
Come back.
Maybe I'm tripping.
Where did she go?
Oh, she's...
Yeah, she's gone.
She was solo.
Solo Della.
Oh, she was serious about getting out.
We should go grab this armor.
Yep.
Let's get this one.
Let's save that evac.
Actually, you know what?
Pop the evac up here.
I'm gonna debate it.
You baited me.
I'm gonna fly back.
I have to take this fucking zip.
You're John.
We'll call our evac up top here.
And just fly on that.
And then we'll go through to wall.
Okey doke.
We should get far from up here.
Wait, so did she actually open that?
Yeah.
Wanna put it here?
Let's put it on this roof.
I think this is the only way to do it.
To get over this checkpoint stuff.
Here you go.
And then we do wanna get that one too.
I think we grab this one first.
And this choke and then get this one.
So we're all in purple.
We just fly this way.
Nice.
Perfect.
Yay, we lived.
I could meet you guys too back here.
If you wanna chill around here.
Not like full split but...
I'm just grabbing this cache.
We'll just start our way over there.
I'm gonna grab this other cache too.
Yeah.
Grab this guy.
We should split up there.
That's okay.
I'm on the way to you guys now.
I got my kunai on me.
Grabbing the other cache.
Which way are we going?
We're gonna try and get into a spot.
It's gonna pull it back here.
I'm pretty sure somebody has to be here.
Yeah, probably.
It's gonna definitely pull back there.
I mean we can literally play anything.
Just next to somebody now.
Wait, so what's fast phase?
You phase faster?
You mean like the little time sign you do?
The phasing like...
Can we try to see if there's...
people up here?
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I feel like the wraith should, right?
Yeah, the wraith definitely should.
Go up there, I believe in you.
There's another evac.
I have another evac.
Okay, nice.
It's huge.
Is it good?
Is it safe?
Yeah, it's super safe.
Yeah, fence this and then people can't even get up here.
Just like put a little fence there.
But we're gonna keep going.
We're gonna try and get like inside the...
Oh, they are.
They're having nades right here though.
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna literally just run up on the bridge.
Just play up top.
We gotta wait for Doki though.
Come here.
Okay.
So there's a team like in the middle and then there's a team right there.
Yep, yep.
Just run up to me.
We're just gonna run up to us.
I knew like we're safe.
There's a crypto.
We're so fucking safe.
That is awesome.
Oh my god.
That's so huge for us.
Yep, that's fine.
Come here, come here.
We gotta be like on Doki.
Get rid of the gem somewhere.
I'll tell you where.
Alright.
Probably right in this corner.
There's a team here, isn't there?
Actually, put it here.
Put it here.
Alright, here?
Yeah.
Just get a bunch of fences.
This is our zone now, fucker.
We make our...
Our space.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
Is that the...
Is that them?
No, no way.
How far are you from purple, Doki?
143.
Okay.
You wanna just punch these people?
Try and get it?
No way, Neampy.
No way!
And that didn't EMP theirs?
No way.
Alright, come over here, Sage.
Let's just like chill here without any...
Dang!
She slapped the hell out of me!
I'm so sorry.
That's not Doki!
Wait, this EMP...
This car didn't even break.
No, it didn't.
It didn't reach all the way over there.
It stopped like right here at this box.
So that was really ridiculous.
No way.
I can't believe it.
Our zone.
Yeah, the team just landed right on top of us.
Yep, yep.
I have ult in 34.
This team just hit the beacon.
Let's see where they go.
Okay.
They're just chillin' there.
Probably just gonna pull here, yeah.
Okay, we have all this space.
We should be fine.
Yep.
Here, you want a phoenix?
Oh, they're just fist fighting!
Wait, they're fighting right now!
They stole their car!
No way!
Do you wanna hit them?
Do you wanna punch him?
Do you wanna get your purple?
Bro, I can't fucking do this.
Wait, I think this is your fence.
That's your fence.
Oh, it is your fence!
It is?
Oh, it is!
I can't tell!
You're like, uh...
There's so many fences!
I just saw red!
Oh my god, they took back the car!
Holy shit!
Here, come put like four fences here.
You know what I mean?
Like, put them across.
Make like a box here.
Is that designing it?
It is, yeah.
Yeah, make us a box right here.
Just like a... Bro, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, they did something here.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Fuck off!
Here we go.
Put like one in each corner here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make a little square.
A little square.
Perfect.
Alright, are we staying under here then?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Bro, fuck off!
Design's trying to kidnap you!
Back up, back up, back up!
Oh, my god.
Oh, that's a good strat!
Let's make a kidnap thing.
Alright, put four fences and like a diagonal...
He's not happy!
Oh my god.
Oh, you went through.
Yeah, you're gonna have to come back.
Yeah, I don't have fences here.
Right back.
Good shit.
That was great.
He's not happy.
Oh my god.
There's another team right here.
He's so weird.
Design is so weird.
Why is he mad?
Oh, that's bad.
Cue right away.
After he said that.
Oh, it's a portal!
It's a portal!
After he said that too.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
My Discord crashed.
What the fuck?
Oh, my Discord crashed.
Whoa!
Oh, it crashed?
I didn't even know.
I was trying to tell you to put fences.
Yeah.
Where did you want me to put it?
Here, put four fences in a little diagonal thing.
So put one right here.
Okay.
And one corner and then one diagonal of it.
And then one like right here.
And then connect the two diagonal ones.
Weee.
And then...
Put one...
Wait, hold on.
Pick this one up right here.
This one?
Okay.
I'm like confusing you.
Yeah, yeah.
Put one fence... put like in a smaller square.
We're gonna try and do a kidnap thing.
Okay.
Wait, actually, you know what?
We should move for the zone, I think.
Okay.
Come over here.
Come to me.
You have gen?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on, I'm gonna see if up here is better.
Here, come up to me.
Climb up to me.
Alright.
Ooh.
Hello guys.
I got that car like right there.
Climb up.
Climb up to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then put your gen right here.
Why?
It's here now.
Right here, right here.
We're punching everyone off.
Whoa.
Alright, this is our new spot.
Are you okay?
It's okay?
No.
They like ran me over with the car.
I couldn't move.
They were trying to jump.
They were trying to trap you with the car.
Oh my god.
Back up.
Yeah, we're punching everybody off of us here.
Alright, here we go.
Our spot now.
This is like my mode.
This is all I'm good at in this game, actually.
Okay, but what if... Oh, they have a gen.
You could actually fence their car.
If you wanna get them stuck.
Okay.
I need to have my gen up now.
I can't get over here.
I'm 105 off evo.
We don't have any ulti cells, right guys?
No, no, no ulti.
Okay.
Let me know when you get your gen, Doki.
Okay, I have a 27%.
Yep, yep.
Try and punch people for your evo if you can too.
I'm trying.
I'm punching this random guy.
When you're just punching the car, actually do something?
No way.
55.
Punching the car.
Getting my armor.
My 5% armor from the car.
Oh my gosh.
Bro, slowly and surely.
This is crazy.
I got it.
Nice.
I got the two pylons.
Okay.
Perfect.
Do you need a syringe?
No.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
I'm gonna syringe.
Pop a syringe.
Cause of the caustics.
I'm gonna fight the car.
Yeah, and in the final end game, Doki, you're just gonna spam fences everywhere.
And then just like try and you know.
Connect them all and get them down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
This is not fine.
I don't know actually.
Are you okay?
I don't even know how many fences.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have.
I think I have maximum.
Oh, we have a nice spot.
Let's go.
I have the maximum amount of fences.
Oh my god.
They destroyed my fences.
That's fucked up.
And that's why you're stunned.
Look at you.
Oh god.
Look at my fences.
My fences.
Bro.
They do not like your fences.
Wait, Doki.
Can you put some fences here?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From up top.
Just put like a bunch down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just slowly coming up to us.
What do I do?
They are actually trying to push us.
They're just slowly walking up.
Dude.
This thing here too is like...
But that Watson looks like she's panicking.
So I think it's okay.
Make sure you have like all 12 fences down around like everywhere.
Bro.
Stop.
You're stealing our fences.
Oh, they broke the gen.
They broke our gen.
I have gen.
Do you want me to put gen down?
Come put it right here.
Come put gen on me.
Right here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Actually hold it.
Hold it.
Hold your gen.
Hold your gen right here.
I have to heal.
You guys okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm okay.
This caustic.
Oh, this team right here.
Put your gen down.
We have to.
I'm putting.
I might die.
I'm gonna die.
Someone threw their ult on me.
I'm dead now.
I'm dead.
They threw.
Yeah, yeah.
It's up to you, daddy.
You gotta live.
There was too many.
Why did the crypto not ult?
There's no way.
I'm getting hushed.
Oh, crypto.
You have the chance.
I am impressed the crypto saved the ult for that long.
That.
Oh, no way.
I can't believe.
Design head butted me.
He took the time to head butt me.
You know what?
This is crazy.
Now the crypto ults.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
You can totally respawn.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you can totally do it.
Yeah, the worst of them.
Oh my god.
There's actually a lot of cryptos now.
That's crazy.
There were so many cryptos, but yet nobody crypto ulted.
How the fuck was that?
They did not care.
That really sucks.
Yeah, that caustic was just...
Yeah, the caustic was so clutch.
I'm surprised that no one fucking...
I'm surprised that no watson ult ate that caustic ult.
That was in between three different watson ults.
How is that possible?
It's okay.
Not last though.
You'll be 19th and you die.
That's fine.
Look at all the EMPs going off over there.
Oh my god.
That is crazy.
If only we didn't lose our car.
But do you have your...
Do you have a redeploy or no?
I'm gonna valk ult.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
It's gonna be hard to get it off but I'm gonna try.
I gotta do it late though.
My god.
This is stressful.
There's a world here.
Where's the other crypto ult?
At least there's less fences.
Oh my god.
Master fighter banners.
If only.
That would have been so clutch.
Wait, they're resing it in front of you.
Behind.
They're literally there.
Look at them.
They're resing.
I gotta ignore that dude.
This is crazy.
Where's the other crypto ult?
Wait, you can take that E back.
In front of you.
Yeah, yeah.
Good come.
I have to keep my flesh health up though.
Oh my god.
Wait, sand on top of us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sand on top of us.
Don't make your presence known.
Just chill.
Go back up.
Go back up there.
This is the only...
Oh my god.
Get an E back.
E back.
It's not allowed to be valkled.
What the heck.
This is the...
What?
What happened?
Wait, what just happened to me?
I just got killpilled.
I think you valkled on somebody.
Like somebody was on your head.
Like another valk was on your head.
There's no way.
It was a nade?
He got naded on his head.
I actually would have won that game.
Bro!
You actually got hit on the head.
What the fuck?
There's no way.
You actually got goomba stomped.
That's fucking crazy.
It said I died to a vert nade, but I don't even think that happened.
I think I actually died.
It looked like somebody's box or something fell on you.
Yeah, somebody landed on you and you got crushed.
That was actually crazy.
Wait, that is crazy.
Oh my god.
You actually got goomba stomped.
It's terrible.
I think I died midair as I was going up to a vert nade.
Yeah.
That is so unlucky.
That's so rough.
Nice try.
That would have been it.
That would have actually been a crazy comeback.
The goomba stomped.
Holy shit.
I still...
There was barely any crypto alts for how many crypto players in the game.
Yeah.
There was.
That is wild.
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
There was two crypto players and I swear I only saw two crypto alts in the end.
Yeah.
GG's guys.
GG's.
See you guys.
Yeah, bye.
Bye.
Holy shit.
That's actually crazy.
I can't believe he got goomba stomped.
Oh my god.
How is that possible?
Somebody was on top of him and then he died.
Oh my god.
How much money did we make?
I think we made like 1k.
More than 1k.
1.5k.
I'm pretty sure.
I think I made like 1.5k.
Because we had two top 5s and that was like $900.
I think.
I think that was like 900.
Wait, not 800.
Sorry.
Why did I say 900?
$800?
And then we get the $500 entry fee.
So like when we're in there.
When you get in, you get $500 automatically by just playing.
And then like all the other games, I think add up would be 1.5.
I had a great time.
It was fun.
I definitely peaked in the beginning.
I definitely...
My gameplay peaked in the beginning.
And then it was downhill from there.
It gave...
Our placement went downhill from there.
But we got top 5 in two different games.
We got top 5 in two games in a row.
So it was a fun stream.
I had a really great time.
Meeting all these people.
It was fun.
I had a great time meeting everybody.
And it was fucking free money.
We love free money.
Chat.
And that's all that matters.
I'm gonna make sure.
If there's anything else we have to do.
But I'm gonna make sure.
I think we're good to go.
But yeah.
Thank you everybody.
I'm gonna do a guerrilla stream later on on YouTube.
I'm gonna figure out what I wanna do.
But I'll be doing another guerrilla stream later tonight.
And just hang out with all of you guys.
But yeah.
I hope you guys had a fun time.
Meeting everybody.
And talking to everyone.
And getting to know more from the Apex scene.
I had a great time.
That was my first time playing with Jen.
A great time meeting him.
And a great time.
First time playing with Timmy.
And a great time meeting him.
Except for that one time.
That I got confused with Sheila.
When he kept yelling at me about Sheila.
I had a great time though.
The queue.
Alright.
I am going to call it here.
As always everybody.
I'll see you guys next time.
Bye guys.
Bye.